So, wer ist denn hier schon alles da, jetzt ging er wieder instant, der Phipps ist da,
Krigswu Faxe, Krigswu, Crashfluffy, Killfil, KZ86, exellent, so viele Leute schon wieder
am Start. Heute Danny auch am Start, exellent. Ja, was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn heute für
Videos? Bin94 auch da, was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn heute für Videos? Ich habe schon ein
paar random angeklickt und ein paar, die ich letztes Mal gespeichert habe, was empfiehlt
uns den YouTube heute für Videos. Das interessiert mich nicht. Hackermans, Distortion, 5 Milliarden
Euro, dankeschön, exellent. Alter, wir haben jetzt verstanden, dass Corona am Start ist,
ich brauche das nicht auf jeder Startseite. Und wenn ich das schon wieder sehe, regt es
mich schon wieder auf. Ich mache seit Jahren kein Feuerwerk mehr, aber muss man wirklich
alles mit irgendwelchen Verboten regeln. Ist das wirklich notwendig? Muss man wirklich
jeden Scheiß verbieten? Sollen die Leute Feuerwerk machen, wenn sie Spaß dran machen? Ich mache
es seit Jahren nicht, aber wer es machen will, soll es halt machen. Das ist im Freien, da
wird sich jetzt auch nicht ein super Spreader Event zusammenbrauen. Videovorschlag, auch
wenn es lange ist, zeig mal her. Ich glaube, das haben wir schon, haben wir das nicht schon
geguckt? Also ich habe es auf jeden Fall schon geguckt, ich weiß nicht, ob wir es on stream
geguckt haben. Das ist ein bisschen langwierig, das ist ein bisschen langwierig. Und ich spoiler
jetzt nicht, weil man denkt ja, man weiß, wie es ausgeht. Sag mal, mal eine Frage an
die Leute, die die restlichen, die die kompletten Staffeln Mr. Robot gesehen haben. Lohnt sich
das wirklich noch? Ich habe aufgehört zu gucken nach der ersten Staffel. Ich fand die erste
Staffel bis zur Hälfte ziemlich gut und danach naja. Und so naja, dass ich, also die letzte
Episode fand ich ganz mies und deswegen habe ich danach gar nicht mehr weiter geguckt.
Florian sechs, also Florian, ob das so extrem viele sind, das wird mich mal interessieren.
Also es gibt sicherlich die ein oder anderen, die sich an Silvester was zu viel saufen oder
weil das geht ja immer noch oder durch Feuerwerk verletzen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass an
Silvester die meisten Leute, die ins Krankenhaus kommen, eher, ich rate das jetzt einfach,
ich habe keine Ahnung, eher irgendeine Art Alkoholvergiftung haben anstatt sich die Hand
weg zu bollern. Und die gibt es doch weiterhin. Warum nicht? Ich glaube in Kombination ist
es ganz besonders toll. Besaufen und dann sich die Hand weg bollern. Ja, exzellenter
Plan. So sollte man es an Silvester machen. Ich werde an Silvester keins von beiden machen.
Ich werde mich weder großartig besaufen, noch werde ich mir die Hand weg bollern. Ach,
irgendjemand hat auch letztens gesagt, wir sollen uns ein Video angucken und ich habe
dann gesagt, ja ich speicher mir es. Moment, Moment. Ich bin ja immer sehr ordentlich was
meine Bookmarks und so angeht. Irgendjemand hat letztens so ein Video gepost, wo ich noch
gesagt habe, oh nee, das ist bestimmt irgendjemand ein komisches Hexer. Wo ist das denn? Wo
habe ich denn das? Hier LED Strips waren es nicht. Hier, das ist es. Oh nee, das kann
ich mir nicht angucken. Das ist schon so cringe, wenn ich das Thumbnail sehe. Oh nee, das kann
ich mir nicht geben. Okay, okay, okay. Irgendjemand meinte, wir sollten uns das hier angucken.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass das ultra cringe ist. Okay, Odi, zwei Monate, danke schön
für den Sub. Ja, das ist schon mega pain to chat, wenn ich das Thumbnail, wenn ich
das Thumbnail schon sehe Leute. Guckt euch das mal an, das halte ich nicht aus. Das ist
Körperverletzung. Und irgendwie dieser ganze Channel, also mal ganz im Ernst, das sieht
mega nach öffentlich rechtlichem Channel aus. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr warum? Weil es
wieder so auf gewollt hip jugendlich gemacht ist. Only Mädels ist auch schon mal ein Hinweis
bei Technik, dass es sich um irgendwas arrangiertes handelt. Also sprich, es kommen wahrscheinlich
selten vier Mädels zusammen, um Technikvideos zu machen auf YouTube. So, der ganze Channel
schreibt, hier, Funk, ich wusste, guckt es euch an. Alter, es war so klar, es war so
klar, dass es ein öffentlich rechtlicher Crap ist, Alter. Das ganze Ding strahlt das
schon aus. Impression. Welcher, welcher YouTube-Channel, bitte schön, außer irgendein öffentlich
rechtlicher, hat sowas in den Links stehen. Und der Name, so many tabs, das klingt schon
einfach wie irgendein öffentlich rechtlicher Programm-Manager-Typ, der sich gedacht hat,
wir haben noch nicht genug gebührenfinanzierte, komische YouTube-Channels, die die Jugend
ansprechen sollen, aber die Jugend nicht ansprechen, wir brauchen jetzt noch einen.
Genauso sieht dieser Channel aus. So, und wenn ich mir dann schon diese Bildchen angucke,
die gesamten Älteren weiß es schon Bescheid. So funktioniert Hacking wirklich sehr, okay,
wenn wir ganz viel Pains Champs sind nachher, dann können wir uns das vielleicht angucken.
Liest den letzten Abschnitt, ne, das ist jetzt schon klar, das ist ZDF hier. Hier. Richtig
cool GmbH. Ach du, oh, oh, wenn Stonks-Leute versuchen, hip zu sein, Alter. Da, da, da
springt ein der Pains Champ ins Gesicht. Und das witzige ist ja, dass Leute, die dem Alter
sind, wo sie sich vorstellen, dass es die Leute ansprechen soll, ähm, spricht es wahrscheinlich
gar nicht an. Das ist kein Stonks-Mensch, okay, der Name klingt aber sehr nach Stonks-Mensch.
Oh, Pains, Pains Champ. Kann mir das nicht geben, das ist bestimmt übelst, äh, tut
weh. Simplicissimus auch bei Fung, ich weiß, ja. Muss ja nicht alles kacke sein, ich mein,
irgendwo müssen die Gebühren ja hin, dass ab und zu auch mal was halbwegs Gescheites
dabei ist. Der Name ist ans Witz gedacht, ah. Max, wolltest du nicht ein YouTube-Video
machen? Ja, wollte ich. Das Video von Windows-Area, oh nee, ReactOS können wir uns nicht an,
ReactOS, also wir haben ReactOS schon im Stream angeguckt und mal ganz im Ernst, Leute, absolut
unbenutzbar. Komplett unbenutzbar. Also, wozu das, also es ist bestimmt cool für denjenigen
oder für die Leute, die daran programmieren, weil sie was lernen, aber benutzbar für irgendwelche
Sachen, die man halt auch halbwegs stable benutzt, ist es nicht. Das ist, glaube ich,
ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wir haben einen Firefox drauf gestartet, also mein uralt
Firefox und ich glaub, der ist hier in zweiten Stall abgekackt. Ganz, ganz schlimm, nee,
nee, nee, das können wir uns nicht geben. Ich weiß jetzt schon, also, und man sieht
ja auch kaum was zu, wahrscheinlich weil es permanent gecrashed ist, alter, ne. Und außerdem,
wisst ihr was, also Leute, die, also stimmt, es kommt dazu, außerdem läuft es meistens
eh nur in der VM. Und dazu kommt, dass wenn man wirklich Software hat, die nur unter,
keine Ahnung, 98 läuft oder 2000 oder XP oder was auch immer, ja ich weiß gar nicht,
was das, was das, wahrscheinlich ist das eher ein Windows-2000-Kloner, ich weiß es ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht. Zumindest, Software, sag mal mal, Software, die nur unter älteren Windows-Versionen
läuft und die nur auf Hardware läuft, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es das gibt.
Das kann ja höchstens sein, das kann ja höchstens sein, wenn das irgendein Anlagen-Steuerungs-Kram
ist. Na ja, 8000 Leute in ganz Deutschland ist ja wirklich nicht so viel. Ich mein, 8000
Leute, 8000 Leute, wir haben glaub ich, wieviel Corona-Leute haben wir gerade am Tag, 16000
neue Corona-Leute am Tag. Gut, die kommen nicht alles krank aus, aber 8000 ist ja nicht
so, ist doch nicht so viel, bei 80 Millionen Leute, das sind ja gerade mal 0,01 oder so,
Kopfrecht in 2020. Ach Moment, Ohrverletzung, ja. Da müsste ich wirklich mal die Statistik
angucken, wie viele davon ins Krankenhaus kommen, ob das wirklich ein relevanter Teil
ist. Dann könnte ich verstehen, wenn man sagt, man will das nicht, das würde ich, das könnte
ich nachvollziehen. Aber einfach so pauschal, aber einfach so pauschal gesagt, wir müssen
das verbieten, weil, fehlt mir die Begründung, das ist übrigens auch das, was mir bei den
Corona-Massnahmen an sich am meisten auf den Kick geht, nicht die Corona-Massnahmen an sich,
sondern die gefühlte willkürliche Festlegung der ganzen Geschichte. Da müsste man echt
mal gucken, wenn das wirklich ein nennenswerter Teil ist, der sich verletzt an Silvester durch
Feuerwerk und ins Krankenhaus muss, dann könnte ich es verstehen. Aber die Diskussion, ehrlich
gesagt, die Diskussion um Feuerwerk verbieten kommt jedes Jahr. Du musst diese Szene mal,
die haben wir schon, die haben wir uns doch schon angeguckt, die haben wir uns doch schon
angeguckt, die kennen wir doch schon, das kennen wir doch schon, das ist, wo sie mit zwei Leuten
an der Tastatur hacken, wobei, das können wir nochmal gucken, das ist echt geil, das
ist so unglaublich, unglaublich fail, das ist so scheiße, das ist das, wo sie dann
gleich mit zwei Leuten an einer Tastatur hacken, Counter hacken. So sieht das auch immer aus,
man sitzt vor dem Rechner und sagt dann, was ist das, ich werde gehackt und dann flimmern,
by the way, wo wir gerade dabei sind, wir müssen uns erstmal kurz auf diese Sache einstimmen,
ich muss mal kurz meine VM starten, sonst geht das nicht, wir müssen uns mal kurz darauf
einstimmen, mit einer Minute, ähm, passende Hacker unter Malung. Wenn die vor allem irgendwann
starten, dann können wir das auch machen. Übrigens, ich hab gestern nochmal GitHub gepusht,
wir können jetzt Kamerastreams aufnehmen, komplett, ist fertig, ich hab's nicht im Stream
fertig programmiert, ich bin im Offstream immer schneller und das, was wir hier gestern gemacht
haben, hab ich wieder verworfen, ich hab jetzt einfach einen pinken Rahmen drum gemalt und
gut ist. So, ah, yes, excellent. Okay, lass uns mal kurz darauf einstellen, dass wir in
den richtigen Hacker-Modus kommen, ja. Hast du dir was beim Black Friday gekommen, der
Black Friday ist ja erst nächste Woche, die haben ja ihre, das ist auch geil, ne, Black
Friday, es gibt jetzt was, Cyber Monday, Black Friday, Black Friday Week, letztens hab ich
im Radio, ja, ich weiß, ich bin halt 1984 geboren, ja, da kann man das entschuldigen,
dass man abends im Radio hört, da hat irgend einer erzählt, ähm, Möbelhaus Black Friday
Month, Black Friday Monat, Alter, jetzt hab ich mir gedacht, was ist mit euch los, über
was kommt denn als nächstes, ist 2021 Black Friday Year, oder wie? Und mal ganz davon
abgesehen, die Angebote bei Amazon sind, sorry, bei Amazon natürlich, sind zu 99,9999% kacke,
braucht kein Mensch, ein paar Sachen sind ganz gut, vor allem die Amazon eigenen Geräte,
wenn man die braucht, aber da ist mein Bedarf an, also mein Bedarf an Tablets ist wirklich
gedeckt, ich mein, ich hab mittlerweile, wie viel Dinge, 11, 12 Tablets oder so, davon
verwende ich nur noch einen Bruchteil, wozu brauch ich nur mehr Tablets, man kann es
ja auch irgendwie übertreiben. Das einzige, was ich mir eventuell wirklich nächstes Jahr
kaufe, ist ein neues iPad, und ein zweites, da aber dann halt ein neues, und ich hab mir
sogar überlegt, ob ich nicht ein iPad Pro kaufe, ok, jetzt haben wir uns genug drauf
eingestimmt, diesen Schuh haben wir doch auch schon gesehen hier, so, jetzt haben wir uns
genug auf Hacker-Modus eingestimmt, jetzt können wir hier zumachen, jetzt können wir uns das
angucken. I'm getting hacked. Das ist so schlecht, Alter. Major. Pass auf, gleich tippen sie zu
zweit an der Tastatur, das ist so unglaublich fail. Vor allem, kann mir mal einer erklären,
warum hat die eigentlich Labor-Kittel an, und warum sitzen die, das ist ein Labor, egal,
egal, egal. Oh, die krassen Hacker-Mens. Diese Tastatursounds im Hintergrund.
Jetzt wird er erstmal Counterhacked. Und natürlich, natürlich geht, geht ein Computer auch so
los, ja, wissen wir ja alle. Das ist so dumm, das ist so dumm. Das ist so Pains-Champ, wenn
man sich so was anguckt. Ich mein, das ist lustiger Pains-Champ, ich mein, ich glaube,
dass in dem Fall, den Typen, die das gefilmt haben, tatsächlich klar ist, dass es Schwachsinn
ist. Hast du dir eigentlich Mr. Robot angesehen, ja? Hab ich, das war ja grad die Frage, ob
es sich lohnt, den Rest noch anzugucken. Ich hab mir die erste Staffel angeguckt, und ich
fand die erste Staffel bis zur Hälfte richtig gut, und die zweite Hälfte fand ich, naja,
und die fand ich so naja, dass ich mir die zweite Staffel gar nicht mehr angeguckt hab.
Die letzte Staffel ist mega, okay. Vielleicht guck ich, wieviel Staffel hatten das, drei
oder vier? Vielleicht guck ich mir, weil ich brauch eh mal ein bisschen was zu gucken wieder.
Was ist das denn? Florian, was ist das denn? Ah, exzellent. Ein Lötkolben, mit was? Auto,
eine Autobatterie-Lötkolben. Die Chinesen schrecken aber auch vor nichts zurück, oder?
Die schrecken vor nichts zurück. Was ist das, eine Gabel? Also ich meine, das ist irgendein
Board, aber achso, das ist das Board für den Heizhörner. Also es ist, glaub ich, ein äußerst
vertrauenserweckendes Angebot, einen Lötkolben für eine Autobatterie für 1,64. Ich glaube,
das sollte man zuschlagen. Oder vielleicht ist es auch gerade, vielleicht ist es auch
ein bisschen teuer. Ich meine, 1,64 sind immerhin 1,64. Wobei, Leute, ich darf hier nichts sagen,
ich hab mir ja mal aus Spaß an der Freude so einen USB-Lötkolben gekauft von der Weile,
so ein Teil hier. Irgendwie sowas da in der Richtung. Einfach weil es geht, nicht weil
ich es ernsthaft verwenden will, genau, dieses Ding. Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben, es
funktioniert. Es funktioniert nicht wirklich gut, aber es funktioniert. Und für Kleinscheiß
ist das gar nicht so doof. Also ich hab diesen USB-Lötkolben schon öfters verwendet, als
mir lieb ist. Weil ich hab nicht immer Bock, wenn irgendwas Kleines ist, die Lötstation
rauszuholen. Ich hab den echt schon öfters verwendet, als ich das gedacht hab. Aber letztendlich
ist es, es ist eigentlich kacke das Ding. Du kannst damit nichts gescheit heizen, also
nichts richtig heiß machen, manchmal wird es nicht richtig heiß, es verliert total schnell
auch die, es ist, ja, also, gut ist was anderes, gut ist was anderes. Ein erstaunlich guter
Kolben. Da denk ich mir auch immer so. Besser durch eine Powerbank betreiben. Ein feiner
kleiner Kolben, exzellent. Ja, wie gesagt, und der da, die Dinger, die sollen sogar relativ
gut sein. Jetzt los. So. Was das Video, welches Video,
das. Weiß ich, ob das so spannend ist. Was machen die da? Das ist Webinterface geklickt,
das ist glaube ich jetzt nicht so spannend. Und jetzt auch noch mit Rack-Konsole. Ob das
ist nicht so spannend. Ah, du kannst es dir hier angucken, ich glaube nicht, dass es
wie ein Stream spannend ist. Kannste mal speichern. Mal gucken, wenn uns die Videos ausgehen, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass es sonderlich interessant ist. 150 Dollar Laptop, ja, ist bestimmt
gar nicht gut. Oh, ich hab vergessen den Chat aufzumachen. Sonst seh ich wieder, die eröffne
ich. So. Was? WTF? Wo kommt das Video her? Das hab ich gerade aufgemacht. Ah, das hab
ich gerade aus Versehen angeklickt, kann das sein? Ah, irgendwie, wahrscheinlich. Ihr
habt es bestimmt gesehen, ich hab das gerade angeklickt, oder? Huge Network Upgrade. Ok,
das wichtigste, das wichtigste lernen wir hier in dem Video, wartet mal, wartet mal,
wo ist es, wo ist es? Hier. Also das wichtigste ist, man braucht RGB-Beleuchtung in seinem
Server-Schrank. Das, das, äh, jetzt, jetzt fällt mir das zum ersten Mal so richtig auf.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum das bei mir daheim nicht richtig funktioniert. Mir fehlt schlicht
und ergreifend die passende, äh, Stimmung. Aber cool, der hat fast das gleiche Gehäuse
wie ich, das ist, ist das gleiche Gehäuse, wie ich auch gekauft hab damals. Gibt es dieses
Winter wieder einen Gartenstelz? Ja, dazu muss es mal schneien. Wobei die Chancen tatsächlich
ganz gut stehen. Weil gestern war es minus drei. Warum hat der RGB, kann mir irgend einer
den Sinn erklären von der RGB-Beleuchtung, die er da in seinem, in seinem Serverraum
hat? Ich mein, außer, dass es irgendwie, irgendwie cool aussieht, wenn das Rack links von rot
und rechts von blau angeleuchtet wird. Äh, Moins, was ist eigentlich aus deiner Web-App
mit Router-Berechnung für Handwerker geworden? Ja, der Prototyp, der geht seit, keine Ahnung,
drei oder vier Monaten relativ gut. Ähm, mein Arbeitskollege hat sich nicht mehr gerührt
und bzw. nicht mehr darum gekümmert, dass das weitergeht. Und ich hab mir irgendwann
gedacht, ich mach jetzt da auch nicht einfach weiter, ohne dass man mal genaue Beschreibungen
bekommt, was die, was die sich so vorstellen, was ihnen da gefällt, was ihnen nicht gefällt,
was man noch machen müsste. Einfach so ins blau reinprogrammieren ist mir meine Zeit
auch zu schade gewesen für. Ah, Kussi, jetzt versteh ich's. Mit rot werden die Server schneller
und mit blau werden sie besser gekühlt und kälter und sind schneller. Exzellent. Funktionieren
tut das Ding. Funktioniert immer noch. Gut, ich wüsste mal neuen Google Maps API-Key generieren,
aber funktioniert, tut das immer noch. What happens when you delete System 32? Wahrscheinlich
mittlerweile gar nichts mehr. Kann ich mir vorstellen. Okay, also was schauen wir uns
denn als erstes an? Was Faktor, es gibt tatsächlich, na gut, mich wundert mittlerweile nichts mehr,
es gibt zu allem Speedruns. Warum sollte es nicht auch Factorio Speedruns geben?
Ein Hackers Backpack. Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt. Was hat ein Hacker? Ja, okay,
die Katze im Rucksack. Ja, die hätte ich auch im Rucksack. Also wenn ich, wenn ich irgendwas
mitnehmen müsste, dann natürlich die Katze. Okay, was, was hat ein Hacker in seinem Rucksack?
Meint der mit Hacker überhaupt richtig Hacker oder was? Das sieht jetzt aber nicht so hackermäßig
aus, oder? Okay, please anschauen, please. Ja, okay, okay, ist ja gut, chat. Gucken wir uns an.
Excellent. Was fragen sich die Leute? Fragen, fragen, fragen. Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ist das jetzt einfach nur was er täglich dabei hat oder ist das irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Hacksaw-Kram, also irgendwelche? Okay, er hat ein iFixit dabei, das können wir uns tatsächlich mal angucken.
Ich finde das viel interessanter. Oh, oh, erst mal gleich ein Messer, was in Deutschland
verboten ist. Excellent. Ich finde es viel interessanter. Was hat er denn hierhin in der Eck?
Was ist denn das? So eine Art Kamin, der zu ist oder so?
Das Messer ist in Deutschland schon mal wieder verboten, ne? Ich verfolge das ja nur immer so
am Rand, was wieder für neue Regelungen und was sich ändert und alles. Ich blicke da nicht mehr
durch, ehrlich gesagt. Zumindest sind Messer verboten, die man mit einer Hand aufmachen kann.
Ich meine, weil es ja auch denjenigen, der abgestochen wird, interessiert, ob der Typ das
Messer mit einer Hand oder mit zwei Händen aufgemacht hat. Und weil es auch jemand, der
es darauf anlegt, andere Leute zu erstechen, sich dafür interessiert, ob das Messer mit einer Hand
oder mit beiden Händen aufgeht. Genau, das stimmt. Ja, Siegbett hast recht. Man darf es haben,
aber man darf es nicht mitnehmen. Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob man solche Sachen haben
darf. Keine Ahnung. Also mitnehmen darfst du es auf gar keinen Fall. Es ist ja auch so, dass man
seinen Ausweis nicht mitnehmen muss, aber du musst halt einen haben. Okay, wenn für einen Hacker
entscheidend ist, ob das Phone sexy ist. Egal, wir gucken jetzt mal weiter. So eins wollte ich
mir auch schon mal eine Weile holen, so ein Teil hier. Ich habe einen Multitool, das habe ich mal
bei Amazon auch bei irgendeinem Black Friday gekauft. Das ist aber Müll. Und die Leatherman-Dinger
sollen richtig gut sein. Sag mal, übersteuert das Video ein bisschen? Das Video übersteuert,
aber das liegt nicht an mir. Das liegt nicht an mir, das liegt am Video, dass das übersteuert.
Also der Typ, Rektangular ist das. Aber so ein Multitool wollte ich auch schon, so ein ähnliches
wollte ich mir auch schon lange mal kaufen. Die sind aber recht teuer. Was? Ist das so? Der
Ger, der schreibt hier im Chat, als Rettungsmesser dürfen Einhandmesser verkauft werden Einsatzkräfte
und ich glaube auch Fahrtfinder dürfen diese... Ich bin Fahrtfinder. Das heißt, ich darf ein
Einhandmesser besitzen. Exzellent. Ich habe sogar noch die ganzen Abzeichen und Krawatten und
Anzüge und so. Exzellent. Dann ziehe ich mir einfach meine Fahrtfinder-Weste an und dann komme ich mit
dem Einhandmesser an. Nein, ich war wirklich relativ lang Fahrtfinder. Bestimmt, bestimmt zehn Jahre
lang. Pics please. Okay, ja, da gebe ich ihm rechten Kopfhörer, den möchte ich auf jeden Fall auch mitnehmen.
Warte mal, dass das Video übersteuert, klingt nicht an mir. Wie? Keine Rolex-Krone. Okay, eine Uhr habe ich gar nicht
mehr. Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht. Früher hatte ich immer eine Uhr am Handgelenk dran zum
Gucken, aber seit ich den ganzen Tag mein Smartphone dabei habe, habe ich keine Uhr mehr an. Also ich
habe die letzten zwölf Jahre oder... Ne, seit wann hat man Smartphones? Ne, nicht zwölf Jahre. Seit den
letzten zehn Jahren, sagen wir mal. Letzten zehn Jahre habe ich keine Uhr mehr dabei. Moment, was? Er hat wirklich... Was mit dem Rolex? Ah, das ist ein Nachbauer, okay. Von zwanzig bis
dreißig Fahrtfinder? Ne, ne, von... Ich würde sagen von zwölf, dreizehn bis 22, 23 oder so war ich Fahrtfinder. Aber ich hatte dann keinen Bock mehr. Warum du französische Verben
bekommst? Ich weiß es nicht. Poggers, Poggers. Ne, also eine Uhr würde ich nicht mitnehmen. Ich würde keine Uhr mitnehmen. Okay, würde ich auch nicht mitnehmen. Brauche ich nicht.
Wusstet ihr gar nicht, dass Hacker neuerdings Kameras dabei haben? Okay, das muss natürlich sein.
Excellent.
within the last couple of years where I left the house without this backpack and that's
pretty much it I carry it with me all the time. What we're gonna do is we're gonna kind
of go through it pocket by pocket, starting from the top to the bottom.
Oh, was? Es ist ja kein Rolex, es ist ein Rolex Nachbau, hat er gesagt. Das ist ja kein
Montana Black Everyday Carry.
The pocket doesn't have anything in it because it's broken.
Wie heißt der Typ, gute Frage.
First of all, the backpack is made by a company called OGO. I don't have the specific model,
but I will link to it on Amazon in the comments down below or in the description of the video
rather. Now, in this first pocket, I have a couple of basic things, the first of which
is what I call the Doomsday database. This is actually a 4 terabyte solid state drive
in a little enclosure that is basically a backup of all of my favorite music, movies
and TV shows as well as common resources that I use.
Okay, also, movies, TV shows, nur würde ich nicht als Backup machen, aber den Backup
dabei zu haben oder verschlüsselt dabei zu haben mit den wichtigsten Sachen finde ich
gar nicht schlecht, weil es könnte ja immer sein, dass du heimkommst und das Haus steht
nicht mehr.
Also zumindest soweit die Weltuntergangslogik, die ja immer erzählt wird, aber die Chance
besteht ja, dass du auf die Arbeit gehst und kommst heim und das Haus ist abgefackelt,
die Chance ist da. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass die Chance sonderlich hohes, aber die
Chance ist nicht Null, es ist ja eh fast nichts Null und dann ist man bestimmt froh, wenn
man die wichtigsten Sachen Backup in seinem Rucksack hatte.
Alternativ kann man natürlich auch die Backups irgendwie in die Cloud schieben, verschlüsselt
das ist ja durchaus eine Variante. Einfacher ist es aber auf jeden Fall damit.
Now moving on, we also have my old OnePlus phone, this is a rooted OnePlus 6T that is
actually not broken, I thought this one was broken, with the original carbon case on it.
I keep this as kind of like a pocket server because it has a self-contained battery, it
does mobile hotspotting and because it's rooted I can run pretty much any Linux tools that
I need to run on here and it's basically a pocket server.
Moving on from there, we have this awesome little, I believe it is called the TS100 soldering
pad.
Das ist cool, das ist cool, das weiß ich eben auch auf Amazon gezeichnet. Das ist wirklich
nice. Also würde ich mir so ein Ding kaufen und würde so einen Pack zusammenbauen, würde
ich es wahrscheinlich auch mitnehmen. Das Teil ist zum Zeitstum, ja aber Zeit stoppen
kannst du doch mit einem Smartphone genauso gut, wenn du es dabei hast.
Das ist, wisst ihr was das witzige an diesem, an diesem Lötkolben ist? Man kann das sogar
Custom Firmware drauf machen, habe ich gesehen. GitHub Custom Firmware ist für Lötkolben.
Das ist natürlich genau das Richtige für mich, erstmal den Lötkolben flaschen. Ja
sowas dabei zu haben ist auch nicht verkehrt. Also wisst ihr, wisst ihr was ich für Netzteil
mitnehme? Ich würde auf jeden Fall Netzteil mitnehmen, ich zeige euch mal was für Netzteil
ich mitnehmen würde. Ich würde dieses 3 Volt bis 12 Volt, ich würde so ein Teil hier mitnehmen,
sowas hier in der Richtung, mit diesem Adapter Set. Was für ein Hacker ist der Kerl jetzt,
das würde ich auch gerne wissen, ja so krasse Hacker Sachen habe ich hier keinen. Aber das
würde ich mitnehmen, da hast du nämlich die besten Chancen, dass du irgendwie das Zeug
betrieben kriegst. 3 bis 12 Volt ist quasi zu 95% das was man braucht und die passenden
Adapter, die man dabei hat, gehen auch für fast alles. Das Netzteil würde ich wahrscheinlich
mitnehmen. Weil natürlich kann man sich auch noch so einen Netzteil mitnehmen, wo du die
Spannung selbst einstellen kannst, aber ganz ehrlich, 3 bis 12 reicht 95% aus. Was habt
ihr so hier, was habt ihr an Geräten die was anderes als 3 bis 12 Volt brauchen? Da fällt
mir jetzt nichts ein, damit könnt ihr alles aufladen, damit könnt ihr im Zweifelsfall
LND Straps betreiben, was auch immer. Ja der Laptop, das ist es auch gar nicht mit gemeint,
es geht alles irgendwo. Unterwegs. Gut, du kannst der Laptop nicht aufladen, das stimmt.
Er ist TikTok Educator, sowas gibt es? Aber der Lötcom ist wirklich Porgas. Und noch
eine Runde Lötzin dabei, jawoll. Also mein Everyday Carry ist ehrlich gesagt eigentlich
nur mein Smartphone, das wars. Und meine Fahrkarte, wenn ich rausgehe. Okay, Stift dabei
zu amüsierlich auch nicht verkehrt. Leco, haben wir uns letztens schon angeguckt, ich
glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie großartig, ach Moment, das ist das Notebook. Wir hatten
letztens das Smartphone davon angeguckt, ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass ich das großartig
durchsetze. Diese ganzen Open Source Hardware-Dinger kranken immer an einigen Stellen leider, deswegen
glaube ich nicht, dass das eine Ausnahme ist. Erstmal schön exzellent, China. Eine Powerbank
habe ich auch im Rucksack. Was zu schreiben habe ich auch tatsächlich im Rucksack, aber
den Rucksack habe ich nicht immer dabei. Eine Powerbank ist echt eines der wichtigsten
Sachen, die man haben kann. Da ist ein Oszilloskop dabei? Jeden Tag. Also ich komme, also ich
komme selten irgendwo vorbei wo ich mir denke, aha jetzt könntest du mal so ein Oszilloskop
gebrauchen, aber komm drauf an, je nachdem was er macht. USB, ne, das ist nicht verkehrt,
das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll. Ich brauche abgeschirmte Netzwerkkabel.
Ich habe die Logitech MX Mastermouse. Ich bin fest davon, dass es das beste Maus ist,
das je gemacht wird. Ich habe sehr große Hände und diese Maus befindet mich perfekt. Es
hat beide eine Multi-Scroll-Wahl hier, d.h. wenn es ansteht, hast du Klicks, wenn du
langsam scrollst, oder wenn es in diese Linie-Aktuation geht. Du weißt, es gibt keine Klicks, wenn
du schnell scrollst, wird es weiter scrollen. Ehrlich eine Maus dabei zu haben ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so doof. Mittlerweile ist ja alles, was man sich so
kaufen kann in diesem Bereich, sei es irgendwelche Multi-Tools oder irgendwelche Ausrüstungen,
das ist heute alles Tactical. Ich kriege das immer auf Amazon empfohlen, vom Tactical
Light bis zum Tactical Tomahawk ist da alles dabei. Ich glaube, normales Equipment gibt
es heute nicht mehr, es gibt nur noch Tactical Equipment.
Jetzt kommt sein Oszilloskop oder sein Notebook, Tablet.
Ja, Leute, die Maus war nicht Tactical, die war tactile, aber wenn du dir heute Equipment
kaufst, das ist mir nur dabei eingefallen, ist es fast alles Tactical, Tactical Glasfaser,
genau.
Also wahrscheinlich würde ich auch lieber ein Tablet mitnehmen als ein Notebook, weil
Notebooks sind ziemlich schwer und da hätte ich keinen Bock, das hier noch zusätzlich
mit rumzudragen.
Okay, da hat Multimeter mit einem Oszilloskop dabei, das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Ehrlich gesagt, den Oszilloskop-Teil würde ich wahrscheinlich so gut wie nie brauchen,
aber Multimeter dabei zu haben ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht übel.
Warte mal, was das Ding für eine Auflösung hat, wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig, eine Auflösung
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein.
Nee, Link denke ich auch nicht, dass das gute Specs hat.
Für Noobs, was bringt es, du kannst zum Beispiel gucken, ob es irgendwo Signale drauf sind
oder sowas, ne, also wenn du irgendwelche digitalen Signale hast, das sind ja meistens
mehr oder weniger gerade, wie nennt man das, sind keine Wellen, es sind, was ist denn das,
Huppel, wie ist da das richtige Wort für, Flanken, Flanken, genau, Flanken, weggeflankt.
Ja, und du siehst ja, bei so einem digitalen Signal hast du ja meistens sowas hier in der
Richtung, ne, und das kannst du im Oszilloskop ganz gut messen, du kannst im Oszilloskop
beispielsweise auch erkennen, ob du irgendwelche Störsignale oder so drinne hast, also wenn
du dich fragst, so, warum brummt das, dazu muss natürlich die Auflösung dementsprechend
sein und weiß ich nicht, ob das hier so ne gute Auflösung hat.
Zum Beispiel, mal angenommen, du programmierst irgendwas zum Steuern von nem Motor oder zum,
oder irgendwie, irgendwie nen Microcontroller, der 50 mal die Sekunde irgendwas machen soll,
irgendwie nen Pin schalten soll oder sowas, und du willst wissen, ob das alles funktioniert
oder, oder mal angenommen, du wunderst dich, warum das manchmal buggt, so nach dem Motto
95% funktioniert, 5% funktioniert nicht, und dann hast du irgendeinen Logic Analyzer oder
irgendein Oszilloskop, machst das dran, schneidest das mit und stellst vielleicht fest, ah, okay,
ab und zu sind die Timings einfach ein bisschen verschoben, jetzt weißt du auch, warum das
5% mal nicht funktioniert, und dann musst du gucken, dass du das Zeug anders programmierst.
Ich, ehrlich gesagt, ich hab keinen Oszilloskop und ich hab auch kaum nen Anwendungszweck
für, ich hab, ich hab nen Logic Analyzer, das ist, ich hab so nen, so einen hier, der
ist wirklich cool, äh, kann mir diesen, ich kann diesen Name nicht, wie der, Salalagilagilogic
Analyzer, wie kann man nicht, das ist so eine Herstellung, den kann man nicht schreiben,
den kleinen, aber ich hab den ganz kleinen, ich weiß nicht, ob es der Logic 8 ist, ich
hab den aller, übrigens das sind China Nachbauten, ähm, die sind ein bisschen günstiger, der
normale kostet glaube ich 150 Euro oder irgendwie sowas, der kleine von denen und die China Nachbauten
kosten halt 10 Euro, ja, Logic 8, oder sogar 340, das ist, ich muss jetzt echt mal gucken,
was ich mir dafür eingekauft hab, ich muss mal kurz bei Amazon reinschauen, ähm, was
ich mir dafür eingekauft hab, weil ich bilde mir einen, der war nicht, nicht so teuer,
so ein klein hab ich hier, genau, aber nicht, aber nicht für den Preis, Alter, ähm, ich
guck mal kurz bei Amazon, was interessiert mich jetzt, kann man da Custom Firmware drauf
klatschen, keine Ahnung, aber die funktionieren auch so ziemlich gut und brauchen keine Cloud,
ja, also die China Dinger, die tun halt so, als wären sie ein offizielles Gerät und
können die Software von denen verwenden, aber, äh, die hier sind schon, die sind schon besser,
aber, äh, okay, Your Orders, ich muss mal gucken, was ich mir dafür eingekauft hab und was ich
dafür, damals für eine Kohle für ausgegeben hab, Sa-L-E-I, wie kann man sich so nennen,
Alter, das ist ja grausam, äh, hab ich das doch nicht bei Amazon gekauft, ich find's
doch nicht bei Amazon, ich find's nicht, hm, dann hab ich doch nicht bei Amazon gekauft,
na gut, was man damit machen kann, ist sowas hier, muss man uns einfach nur mal die Bilder
angucken vom Hersteller, du kannst zum Beispiel mitschneiden, wenn du irgendein digitales
Signal hast, kannst du mitschneiden und dann reinzoomen und dir angucken, was es macht,
äh, haben wir da mal irgendwelche schöne, schöne Bildchen zu, ja, das hier ist ein
schönes Beispiel, sowas kannst du damit machen, guck, du schließt das, du hast 8, du hast
8 Input-Channels, moin, Sebaro, du hast 8 Input-Channels und, ähm, dann schließt
du, das ist beispielsweise hier ein SPI-Signal, dann schließt du das hier an und dann siehst
du genau, was dort passiert drauf, da siehst du zum Beispiel, ok, auf deinem, hier ist
der, der Takt, hier ist das Takt-Signal drauf und hier hast du dann die, die Data-Pins irgendwie
und dann siehst du, ok, was wir da übertragen, das braucht man zum Beispiel, wenn man versucht,
irgendwas nachzubauen, wozu es nicht so richtig offizielle Spezifikationen gibt, ähm, also
warum ich mir das damals gekauft habe, ist folgendes, ich wollte damals mit einem Arduino,
ähm, nachbauen, ich versuche, ich überleg grad, wie das Ding heißt, ähm, so, ich hatte,
ich hatte so ein super Micro-Wechselrahmen für Festplatten, mit Lichtern vorne dran,
so was, so ein Ding, so ein Ding hatte ich, so, und das hat hier neben Lichter, wo man
sieht, ob die Platte kaputt ist und so war es in der Richtung und das steuert man über
einen extra Protokoll an, wozu ich keine offizielle Implementierung irgendwo gefunden hab und
da hab ich mir damals gedacht, weißt was, Logic Analyzer anschließen, gucken, was das
überträgt, das Protokoll an sich ist relativ simpel und dann wollte ich das mit einem Arduino
nachbauen, dass ich das ansteuern kann, ja, hab ich aber ehrlich gesagt nie gemacht.
Diese Portable-Dinger, da hab ich immer meine Bedenken, ob die was taugen, Pocket-Multi-Meter,
nee, sowas brauchen wir nicht, nicht, nicht, das ist 500 IQ, ja, ich bin echt, ich muss
mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz in meine Mails gucken, was ich mir da gekauft hab, ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher, gab's mal ein Logic 4 oder so, ich hab die allerkleinsten gekauft,
das weiß ich noch, ja, da kommen wir preislich ungefähr in die Region, wo ich mir damals
was gekauft hab, ich hab nicht so extrem viel Geld ausgegeben, ist da die Backplane drin,
ja, ich suche jetzt mal kurz nach Salalage in meinen Mails, irgendwo muss ich die Versandbestätigung
noch haben, ähm, hier?
Logic 4 hab ich bestellt, ihre Bestellbestätigung, guten Tag Max, vielen Dank für Ihre Bestellung,
den hab ich gekauft hier, für 108 Euro damals, den da, hab's gefunden, was kostet der heute,
China Dinger, warum kostet der heute das doppelte und dreifache, als damals, huge Schwertentwicklung,
hätt ich mal, hätt ich damals mal 50 gekauft und heut fürs dreifache verkauft, Stonks,
NextBitcoin, Logic Analyzer Coin, ja, also den hab ich damals gekauft, den Logic 4, ne,
wir haben noch kein Stonks Emote, aber wenn du ein gutes hast bei FFZ oder bei TwitchTV,
dann, ähm, ach guck mal, hier kostet er auch nicht mehr so viel, ja genau, dieses Ding,
dieses Ding hatt ich damals gekauft, so für um die 100 Euro, ja, richtig poggers, das ist
auch wichtig, dass es zwischen 2,5 und 5,5 macht, äh, Levels, weil ansonsten kannst
es mit manchen Sachen nicht verwenden, na gut, was auch immer, ja, gucken wir mal weiter,
bisschen Side-Tracked worden wieder, aber das kennen wir ja nicht anders, beta-twitch-tv-stonks,
ok, add to channel, bäm, ist drinne, hab's geedit, wobei es sicherlich bessere Stonks
emote gibt, ihr müsst aber refreshen und, und, ähm, das dauert ein bisschen bis FFZ
das gesüngt hat, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha,
aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, live, live, live, live, live, live, live, live.
life saver and it was a fantastic christmas present from my parents excellent moving on
last but not least except for the main pouch is my laptop my laptop is a dell 15
da weiß ich ob es reicht wenn man den einfach mal ausschalten und wieder einschaltet
ich glaube das reicht nicht ich glaube man muss das irgendwie reconnecten
naja gut ich werde es überleben diesen stream ohne stonks vorschau
er hat ein tablet und ein laptop dabei ok jetzt wird es ein bisschen schwer vor allem
was was hat er drauf wenn ich habe es gar nicht gesehen
oh ja carbon fiber das ist ganz wichtig für richtigen
ok den habe ich mittlerweile ja auch ich muss euch aber ehrlich sagen mich hat
jetzt dieses ifixit set zumindest die teile die wir letztens im stream probiert haben nicht
sonderlich impressed ich meine guckt mal dieser eine dieser eine das eine teil was sich sofort
verbogen hat war jetzt sicherlich nicht so die dolle qualität der eine spachtel da ja
steigt direkt gleich verbogen also mit mit ordentlichen werkzeug wenn das nicht passiert
der rucksack wiegt 50 kilo wahrscheinlich
da hat er schon airpods dabei die konkurrenz davon ich habe die bose konkurrenz davon wobei
ich absolut kein bose fan bin aber das waren damals so die einzigen sinnvollen diesmal gab in
einem angebot und die sind eigentlich auch ganz gut vielleicht wird man heute auch die holen das
stimmt habe ich habe ich noch nie probiert dass das ist müsste ich aber ich bin noch nie mit
neues cancelling headphones ins rz gegangen
wäre mal eine idee mal gucken wie gut die da funktionieren aber so gerade mit konstantem
lüfter rauschen müssten die ziemlich gut klarkommen
zeig mal die spachtel wo ist die spachtel ja aber dem ist ja auch schon verbogen sonst
wäre die gar nicht mehr gar nicht mehr drin guck mal bei dem ist das auch verbogen die ist
nicht mehr drin das ist ja witzig bei ihm ist die spachtel auch nicht mehr da dafür
hat er jetzt eine schere drin was falls du mal ein oscilloskop suchst das voltcraft ds
o 1062 d excellent produktname wird zwar mit 60 megahertz warm ist aber eigentlich ein
200 megahertz modell von hantek und lässt sich auch mit einem einfachen firmware update anlocken
custom firmware flaschen aufs oscilloskop das ist ja für mich schon mal der grund warum ich
mir gleich mal das kaufen sollte ich brauche aber keins aber das heißt ja nix
teile ich mal her kost
doch geht doch eigentlich
geht doch eigentlich
an 300 euro für den ordentlich aus vollkommen in ordnung
bayernflash nee ich brauche kein oscilloskop ich kaufe mir sachen immer dann wenn ich mal
vor einem problem stehe und sage ah hätte ich jetzt mal xy gehabt und es kommt so gut es kommt
nie vor nicht so gut wie es kommt nie vor dass ich sag ach hätte ich jetzt mal ein oscilloskop
gehabt vielleicht ist das aber auch umgedrehter fall dass man das öfters benutzt wenn man eins
nee das pocket multimeter das habe ich mir letztens ein video angeguckt das hat mir das
war sehr extrem hakelicher krempel
ach bitte ist das schlecht ich kenne mich damit nicht aus
das ist die auflösung oder was ist das
oder was ist was sagt uns das überhaupt ich habe wirklich kein anwendungszweck
zumindest kein regelmäßigen anwendungszweck von oscilloskop wenn ich wirklich mal irgendwelche
levels sehen will dann kann ich den logic analyzer verwenden und wofür wofür bräuchte ich
oscilloskop leute sagt mal ich mir fällt nichts ein bei dem kram was ich mache wozu ich oscilloskop
bräuchte du hast eben den alten delta für 200 euro verkauft exzellent sieht cool aus ja das
war es also ok ok also sollte ich mal dazu übergehen facecam technik videos zu machen
wo ich einen coolen hintergrund brauche dann kaufe ich mir ein oscilloskop und stelle es
hinten hin weil das sieht auf jeden fall sehr technisch und und advanced aus
ansonsten braucht man das nicht
dass sie baro verschenkt stufe 1 abos massif poggers
ja jetzt brauche ich nicht kaufe ich nicht gucken wir jetzt mal den rest vom video an
wir brauchen wieder schon für eine wir brauchen schon wieder für 24 minuten video 3 stunden ja
und dann verbiegt man es erstmal schön also wenn die i fix it wenn die bits auch so stabilen sind
dann habe ich die bits wahrscheinlich demnächst auch kaputt jetzt will das wissen
jetzt will das wissen jetzt will das wissen
als richtig krasse hacker braucht man natürlich auch lockpicks
ok da habe ich keine Ahnung von
komm was sara angucken müsste ich schicken
das ist eine gute idee er schreibt der kopf sich nur sachen die ich noch nicht kaputt gemacht habe
das ist eine gute idee dann weißt du zumindest es hält ein bisschen was aus
jetzt kommt die hacker bands
da steht ja viel drinnen da steht ja viel drauf
die billig usb sticks die jeder hat
ja das braucht man sowas braucht man immer so was braucht man immer kann man auch immer gebrauchen
sd kartenleser und bla bla bla ja
ja so adapters kann man immer mal gebrauchen wo man schon wieder sieht was für ein
abfuck usb eigentlich ist der braucht ja eine ganze tasche voll mit usb adapter auf usb adapter des
usb adapters ein fader 800 megahertz 2,4 megahertz 5 gigahertz wahrscheinlich also die standard
die man sagt sind 2,4 gigahertz 5 gigahertz mittlerweile 800 megahertz und was ist das andere
413 oder sowas noch was auch noch recht verbreitet ist gerade in europa
400 irgendwas megahertz kann man das immer nicht merken laura eu wo sind die dinger
von den antennen die rada hat 433 genau nicht 413 433 ist recht verbreitet und 863 genau
aber wieso weil das öffentlich nutzbare frequenzbereiche sind also was macht der
typ denn das ist ein krasse heckermann keine ahnung was ist was ist das
das ist das ist ein bleistift das ist einfach bleistift oder jetzt
jetzt kommt die heckermanns sachen und meldet sich wahrscheinlich als
tastatur oder sowas außer außer du hast eine wlan logitech tastatur da musst du gar
nix keylogger da kannst du nämlich nicht eine wlan logitech eine logitech funktastatur
die kannst du nämlich einfach so mitschneiden ohne dass du sowas brauchst
sowas ist sicherlich praktisch wenn man krasse heckermann ist braucht man sowas
hier so lange ich bin ja ich bin ja nicht
unterwegs und machte krasse hacker actions ich bin ja hauptsächlich bei mir
daheim und bastel hier rum dann habe ich nicht ich habe schon mal wie gesagt
ich habe schon mal überlegt vor einer weile das habe ich glaube das habe ich
irgendwo auf reddit gelesen in so ein erfahrungsbericht dazu oder so ein
einsatzbericht sollst du mal was kaufen
sister sister sister
er hat da hätte mich schon erwischt mit weil diese usb sticks sehen wirklich so
aus wie die billigste usb sticks dies überall gibt aber sind sie gar nicht
das sind das sind das sind sticks die tun so als werden seine tastatur das ist
eigentlich richtig big brain dass die dinger so aussehen wie eigentlich ist
das mal richtig richtig richtig gut man macht quasi den usb stick also man
baut was was aussieht wie dieser 08 15 usb stick den man überall bekommt diese
ich glaube jetzt mehr ernsthaft leute jeder hatte schon mal ein usb stick der
so aussieht nur dass die hier keine usb sticks sind
sondern eine tastatur also dass sie sich als tastatur anmelden uns und
tastendrücke in computer eingeben und das geht dann ganz schnell
und steckt sein rechner
was ist cool das ding
das klappt in deutschland nicht weil du zu wenig upload speed hast
ok das ist auch
das
Das hab ich jetzt nicht gecheckt, was das macht.
Was hat er uns erzählt mit Nmap und dem USB?
Das hab ich nicht kapiert.
Hast du irgendjemand verstanden, was das macht?
Ja, das hatten wir schon.
Ich mein, das was jetzt kommt.
Automated Nmap Payloads.
Ach, jetzt versteh ich, was das macht.
Das schickt irgendwelche Pakete, die man ihm vorher quasi gespeichert hat oder so.
USB-C Beste.
Oh, es geht ja noch weiter.
Nice.
So einen würd ich auch mitnehmen, ja.
Also wenn ich für so was bauen würde, hätte ich auf jeden Fall den Raspberry Pi Zero mit am Start.
Entfernt er auch HDCP?
Dann könnte man das ja zweckentfremden.
Oh, das ist nice, Winkey.
Was ist, kannst du da einen Hotspot machen oder?
Der hat am Anfang erzählt, was er hier für einen Rucksack hat.
Oder die Tasche. Die Tasche hat er sich bei irgendeiner Konferenz gekauft, hat er glaube ich erzählt.
Exzellent.
Das Ding ist schon nice.
So, das war's für heute.
Das T-Shirt ist...
Auch nice, ja.
Okay, das sind aber echt 5 Kilo Dinger, die er damit sich rumträgt, ja.
Den Controller, ja.
Sogar die Hackermans sind heute schon in der Cloud.
Ich carry meine Hose.
Mit einem Smartphone drin. Das war's ab und zu meinem Rucksack.
Ja klar, den Rucksack muss man erstmal belegen. Das wird meine Augen machen.
Ja, aber trotzdem interessant.
YouTube letzte Chance, noch was ordentliches zu empfehlen.
Warum Deutschland voller Papageien ist.
Was, Battlefield 6 Teaser? Gibt es? Gibt es den echt?
Den da, ja den kenne ich.
Nee, da gibt es doch nichts Neues.
Den Livestream, wo man sieht, wo man neue AMD CPUs kaufen kann.
Das ist auch mal eine Idee.
Livestream, wo gibt es AMD CPUs zu kaufen?
Das ist voll eine gute Idee. Radio alles Stockchecker.
Also eigentlich komplett sinnlos, aber man möchte jetzt auch nicht was kaufen.
Mach mir so einen Stream mit deutschen Seiten.
Eigentlich ist das eine ziemlich, Leute das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Also man könnte sowas machen und dann mit Reflinks.
Das würde wahrscheinlich richtig Geld generieren.
Das muss ich mir aufschreiben, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee.
Man macht so eine Stockchecker Webseite oder Stream.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was da sich am besten eignet.
Und dann macht man das einfach nur mit Reflinks.
Das ist richtig cool, ich glaube damit könnte man echt ganz gut Geld machen.
Das ist eine gute Idee, sowas könnte man echt mal programmieren.
Man muss einfach nur die größten Seiten dann überprüfen.
Abonniert Twitch Prime der Gottbaba.
Vier Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellent.
Jetzt wollen sie uns alle zeigen, was in ihrer Kiste, was in ihrem Rucksack drin ist.
Nachdem wir mal angefangen haben, das jetzt so zu gucken.
Wisst ihr was das Beste ist, um programmieren zu lernen?
Wisst ihr was wirklich das Beste ist?
Bevor ihr euch lange fragt.
Das ist das Beste.
Einfach anfangen.
Nicht sich 30.000 Tutorials angucken vor Leuten, die einem erzählen, wie man es am besten machen muss.
Ja, Berufsschule sackt ja auch.
Wenn du erstmal ein Buch mit 500 Seiten gelesen hast, weißt du danach gar nicht mehr wie es angefangen hat.
Leatherman Multitool Buyers Guide.
Oh, das ist jetzt zu lang, aber das speichere ich mir mal, weil so ein Ding will ich mir kaufen.
So ein Teil will ich mir kaufen, so ein Multitool.
Alter, wie viele haben die denn?
What the fuck?
Wie viel haben die denn?
Ich hatte gar nicht mehr auf.
Ja, aber sonst und sonst und verfügbarkeits...
Tracker ist eine echt gute Idee.
Was schauen wir jetzt?
Das Hotel-Ruhm, geöffnet mit Privacy-Card.
Oh, ganz schön großer Abstand, hä?
Was ist das für eine Tür, Alter?
Das muss doch dem Typ, der das eingebaut hat, aufgefallen sein, dass da ein Loch in der Tür ist.
Wir müssen sogar durchgucken.
Alte NA-Tür, Freedom-Tür.
Das war's für heute, wenn ihr Fragen oder Kommentare habt, schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, dann abonniert, und wie immer, habt einen schönen Tag. Danke.
Also, ganz im Ernst, das muss doch den Typen, die diese Tür gebaut haben, aufgefallen sein, dass die irgendwie nicht ganz dicht ist.
Ich meine, da kannst du ja durchgucken, du kannst ja reingucken, was in dem Raum passiert, und es sollte eine Tür nie so weit auf sein, dass du durch einen Spalt reingucken kannst.
Aliexpress-Tür.
Als nächstes gucken wir nicht.
Gucken wir jetzt auch nicht.
Wir gucken uns noch ein Safe-Knack-Video von dem an.
Okay, das ist wieder typische Kokona-Produkt, sowas brauchen wir in Deutschland nicht. Eine Home-Ding-Security-Pistol-Box.
Ja, wahrscheinlich mit irgendeinem Magnet oder sowas. Der hält jetzt an die richtige Stelle den Magneten des Dinges auf.
Ich sagte doch, der hält irgendein Magnet dran oder sowas. Kommt jetzt.
Ah, ah.
Ja, okay.
Wo wir dabei sind, zu große Schlitz.
Easy. Easy.
Dankeschön, Kofax, drei Monate.
Okay, das ist das wirklich easy als Fakt. Das ist so easy, das würde ich wahrscheinlich auch noch hinkriegen.
Thank you.
Starlink-Unboxing.
Das ist ein schönes Pink. Guck dir das an. Das ist toll. Mit Verizon war ich glücklich, zwei zu bekommen.
Ich bin sehr glücklich darüber.
Also 38 Millisekunden für ein Satelliting ist schon nice. Nee, ich glaube im Test sieht man keinen Packet-Loss, sonst ist das Video also nicht sonderlich spannend.
Ich bin ja eh kein allzu großer Starlink-Fan. Erstens sehe ich die Gefahr bei Starlink, dass man die Erdumlaufbahn mit Dreck zuschleudert und ich halte es für fragwürdig, wie viele Leute man schafft mit Starlink ordentlich zu versorgen.
Kennst du das Video von Simplicissimus über den Chip für das Gehirn von Elon Musk? Nein.
Das mit dem Dreck soll anscheinend kein Problem sein. Er sagt wer? Er sagt Starlink.
Es gibt ja so Sachen, dass ich im Laser den Schrott entfernen kann. Ich sehe da schon ein Problem. Selbst wenn da nur ein Satellit kaputt geht, die Chance, dass der andere kaputt macht, ist auch relativ hoch und der Dreck geht ja nicht von allein wieder weg. Zumindest nicht schnell. Wenn überhaupt.
Und dazu ist fraglich, wie sich die Bandbreite und alles entwickelt, wenn es mal mehr als ein paar Leute verwenden. Wie viele Leute man damit anschließen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da noch nicht so zuversichtlich.
Das interessiert mich jetzt auch nicht so groß.
Warum ist die VU die beste Retro-Emulation-Control? Ich sehe das. Die beste Musik hat die VU eindeutig.
Die beste hier.
Die beste Retro-Emulation-Control.
Nur ein bisschen schneller.
Das stimmt. Echt? Das ist verdammt wenig.
Ja, das frage ich mich auch. Ich habe ja eine gekauft damals.
Nix. Das war aber doch seit Switch Release klar, dass mit der VU nichts mehr ist.
Ja, wenn man V-Sachen spielt, ist eine VU natürlich nicht verkehrt.
Ich muss ja sagen, sowohl die V als auch die VU ist ja quasi ein Gamecube. Da hat sich nichts getan, großartig.
Das stimmt.
Zeig mal her.
Ich habe damals meine Wii gemoddet, dass man eine USB-Fastplatte dran machen konnte.
Natürlich nur für Sicherheitskopien von Spielen, die ich eh besessen habe.
Also ich habe hier noch eine Wii U rumstehen, die auch schon eine Weile keine Firmware-Updates mehr bekommen hat, was wahrscheinlich ganz gut ist, wenn man die Hexen an will.
Kann man eigentlich noch VUs kaufen neu? Gibt es noch welche?
Ja doch, gibt es noch.
Das ist eine gute Idee, das können wir wirklich im Stream machen.
Die auf Amazon, oder? Waren die nicht neu?
Ach nee, haha.
Sind nicht neu.
Hahaha.
Nee, gibt keine mehr.
Gibt nichts mehr.
Alles benutzt, haha. Guter, dass ich noch eine habe.
Muss ich mal gucken, wo ich die hinnehme.
Irgendwo habe ich sie.
Muss ich gerade mal kurz hier in den Schrank gucken, wo habe ich die hier noch irgendwo?
Ich meine, haben, tue ich sie noch, aber ich weiß gerade nicht wo.
Hier neben vielleicht? Ja, da liegt sie.
Da liegt sie.
Exzellent.
Ja, nice.
Könnte mal flashen.
Könnte mal im Stream echt mal probieren zu flashen. Mal gucken, ob der zeigt, wie es geht.
Ich habe sogar noch einen Classic Controller.
Ja, wir können das im Stream flashen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man sowas zeigen darf, aber warum nicht? Das Ding ist ja uralt.
Ich glaube, eine Sensor Bar finde ich nicht mehr.
Das ist aber auch nicht so schlimm, eine Sensor Bar kriegt man bestimmt nachgekauft.
Ich habe beim Umziehen meine Wii weggeschmissen.
Meine Wii und mein N64 habe ich weggeschmissen damals. War eigentlich total bescheuert.
Ja, weil ich nicht nachgedacht habe.
Das ist ja witzig. Man muss einfach nur eine richtige Seite aufdesignen. Jetzt wisst ihr, warum die Switch keinen Browser hat.
Einfach die Wii U Exploit XYZ aufmachen.
Das ist wirklich stark. Ich weiß, das ist ernst gemeint.
Das ist anscheinend alles, ja?
Nintendont.
Was? Man kann Double Dash Online spielen?
Ich hatte die deutsche Version davon, wo Roboter herumgerannt sind.
Das hat mich übelst fertig gemacht, weil man nur zwei Meter gucken konnte.
Das ganze Game besteht aus Nebel. Guckt euch das an. So schlimm.
Wo du den Gegner gleich aus dem Nebel stellst. Das Ding hatte nicht genug RAM einfach.
Garantiert ja.
Das stimmt ja.
Eigentlich witzig, dass die Mario 64, was ja ein N64-Game war, den Source-Code bekommen haben und das jetzt quasi umgebastelt haben, sodass es nicht remastered ist,
sondern auf der Wii U läuft. Das ist voll mindblon, Alter.
Okay, im Prinzip kannst du alles darauf emulieren außer Xbox, außer PS2 aufwärts.
Also sprich, du kannst keine Xbox, du kannst keine PS2. Ob du Playstation 1 machen kannst, vielleicht.
Leistungsfähig genug müsste das Ding sein, aber Playstation 1 ist ja bekannt dafür ein bisschen tricky zu sein mit Bios kopieren und allem Möglichen.
Und alles weitere geht natürlich nicht. Ich meine, sollte jedem klar sein, dass du keine PS3 auf dem Wii U machen kannst.
Aber kostet nicht Spiele noch so viel, weil es Nintendo ist.
Aber weil es Nintendo ist.
Ja gut, Raspberry Pi sagt ja auch von der Leistung her, da ging es ab.
Okay, das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Excellent.
Sehr gut, wow. Übertreib halt mit der Outro-Musik.
So, jetzt können wir uns jetzt angucken. Wir können uns wohl nur Battlefield angucken.
Top 10 3D Printable Tools Every Maker Should.
Und was? Like Make. Aha.
Da gucken wir uns das mal an. Der Dude ist so, was hat denn der da eigentlich auf? So ein Fake-Google-Class oder was soll das sein?
Der Dude ist so cool, schau dir das neueste von dem an. Der hier oder was?
I made the worst test among us in real life.
Ich spiele keine among us, ich kenne mich damit nicht auch.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was ich unbedingt für Tools printen sollte. Ich benutze meinen 3D Drucker eh zu wenig.
Also mal gucken, was es da für Poggers-Dinger gibt.
So ein hätte ich mir auch fast gekauft.
Das war mir dann doch ein bisschen teurer. Da hättest du ungefähr 1000 Euro für ausgehen müssen.
Da waren mir lieber 220 oder was meiner gekostet hat, waren mir erstmal lieber zum Einstieg.
Ob der den Kram hier auch selbst gedruckt hat? Bestimmt, das ist bestimmt selbst gedruckt.
Okay, das brauche ich nicht. Okay, das brauche ich nicht.
Ich meine es ist auf jeden Fall cooler als so ein fertiges Maus Bungee, aber das ist sinnlos.
Zumal ich mittlerweile eh einen Wireless-Maus habe.
Ich brauche auch keine.
Es sieht aber geil aus. Ich finde es sieht geil aus, wenn man diese Timelapse vom 3D Drucker sieht.
Wer will sowas? Ja, frage ich mich auch.
Okay, das ist ganz nice, also so sieht es jetzt ganz nice aus, aber ganz ehrlich ist es wahrscheinlich relativ unpraktikabel.
Mal gucken, was noch kommt.
Das Ding zu drucken dauert wahrscheinlich wieder 50 Stunden oder so, das druckt ja ewig.
19 Stunden, easy.
Aber ihr müsst ja mal eins sagen, also diese Timelapses sehen schon geil aus.
Ich habe mir das Plugin auch installiert, um Timelapses zu machen. Ich verwende es aber irgendwie nicht.
Aber Timelapses von 3D Drucken sehen schon cool aus.
Timelapses haben echt was.
Top Sachen, die keiner braucht, schon so ein bisschen.
Grill.
Was sind Alltoys?
Hast du es eigentlich geschafft die andere Leiste zu flaschen? Welche? Ich habe viele Leisten geflasht.
Du meinst das, wo ich mich so schwer getan habe aufzubekommen im Stream?
Du meinst diese Gosund Doppelsteckdose?
Wenn Corona vorbei ist, benennen die sich übrigens in Gesund um.
Aber ich glaube den Witz habe ich gestern schon mal gemacht, der ist eigentlich so schlecht.
Ach, das ist für Batterien. Okay, das braucht wirklich keiner.
Nein.
Ja, aber wozu?
Warum?
Okay, das ist cool, aber why?
Ich meine, die, die du nicht mit dem Pile flaschen konntest, seitdem bin ich nicht mehr auf dem neuesten Stand.
Welche ist denn das? Ach, die. Nee, die habe ich zurückgeschickt, weil die sah zwar genauso aus wie die andere, die man flaschen konnte.
Hat aber einen anderen Controller drin gehabt.
Die habe ich zurückgeschickt, da war ein MediaTek drin.
MediaTek Controller kann man nicht flaschen.
Ja, aber das passiert mir eigentlich nicht.
Also Battle Wolf, wenn du diese, diese, diese, wenn du diese Leiste hier meinst.
Die, die so aussieht wie die hier.
Die habe ich mir nämlich bestellt von einem anderen Hersteller und der hatte MediaTek CPU drinnen.
Konntest du nicht flaschen. Ich habe die aufgeschraubt reingeguckt, weil MediaTek drinnen.
Ah, diese Timelapses sehen cool aus.
MediaTek, ja.
Gut, weil man viele unterschiedliche Schrauben hat und öfters raussuchen muss, ja.
Man könnte die Schrauben einfach in so ein Kästchen machen.
Also Battle Wolf, wenn du die bei AliExpress gekauft hast, sind die Chancen, dass ein ESP-2866 sogar relativ hoch ist, weil die Chinesen stehen auf den Controller.
Das sind die, die so ein dreieckigen, dreieckige Schrauben unten drin haben zum Aufmachen.
Schick mir mal, schick mir mal den Link von AliExpress, wo du gekauft hast.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob man da irgendwas erkennt, was das für eine CPU ist.
Nö, ich habe so wenig gedruckt, dass ich die Filamentrolle und die Probefilament Sachen, die bei meinem Drucker dabei waren, noch nicht leer habe.
Das Problem hatte ich noch nie.
Okay, wenn man es braucht. Mein 3D-Drucker hat neben so eine Rolle, die hängt auf so einem Stab drauf und rollt halt einfach. Das Problem hatte ich bis jetzt noch gar nicht.
Wozu?
Warum, warum sollte ich meinen Controller auf ein Skateboard setzen?
Wieso nicht? Ja, das ist eigentlich die eine richtige Frage.
Das wackelt doch wie Sau. Das wackelt doch wie Sau. Ey, das wackelt wie Sau.
Guck doch mal, wie das wieder so näher wackelt unten. Guck mal hier, das fällt doch gleich um.
Da hätte ich ja per mal Angst, dass man eine Rolle umkippt. Was ist auf jeden Fall eine ZLD444EUW?
Ja, gucken wir mal, ob wir die flaschen können. Äh, mit das Motor flaschen.
Ja, wenn da ein ESP drin ist, dann kannst du die flaschen. Das scheint kein Media-Attack zu sein. Ist halt schwierig zu sehen.
Da scheint tatsächlich ein ESP2866 drin zu sein. Dann kannst du flaschen.
Gut, ich weiß gar nicht wozu. Ich mein, wie gesagt, an meinem Drucker ist neben so eine Halterung für eine Rolle.
So, warum brauche ich dann irgendwelche komischen Dinger, wenn ich die Rolle einfach hier dran hängen kann?
Guck mal, einfach habe ich ein Bild mit einer Rolle dran. Warum, warum die Rolle nicht einfach daneben dran hängen und alles ist gut?
Ist das zu einfach? Ja, weil es Drucker gibt, die sowas nicht haben. Ja, das ist mir schon klar dafür, aber ich meine, die meisten Drucker haben doch sowas, oder?
Ich meine, das ist einfach ein Stab nebendran und im Zweifelsfall kann ich einfach an jeden x-beliebigen Drucker so einen Stab dran machen und eine Drucker und eine Rolle dran hängen.
Every bit of surface mount soldering I do uses either solder paste or flux.
The best way to deliver that from the tube to the pad is this Pyco paste press.
A mechanical paste press is the best way to deploy a precision blob of the good stuff right where you need it.
Problem is, this Pyco model got discontinued like five years ago.
Enter the dispenser for syringe of flux or solder paste. Awful name, decent model. This thing is kind of awkward to print, it has a goofy rubber band on it.
It's not nearly as smooth as the Pyco model, but it gets the job done.
This thing doesn't need screws. This thing doesn't need threaded rod or any other weird hardware. All you need is some filament, some screws, some spongey and a rubber band.
If you do any surface mount work at all, you've got to get one of these.
Even though it is, I'll admit, really janky, the others are definitely jankier. Maybe I'll make my own one day. I hope not.
You could run off two copies of everything else on this list and still have enough plastic left for a full-size copy of that stupid, stupid, stupid, stupid baby Groot.
Well, we're throwing that out the window, because number one is...
Baby Groot hat wahrscheinlich jeder mal versucht zu drucken.
Number one, workbench storage, Dremel bit storage...
Ach du Scheiße, das druckt ja, das druckt jetzt wirklich 50 Stunden.
Alter, Alter, das druckt ewig. Das, oh. Alter.
Aber das ist, ey, das ist sogar wirklich nützlich.
Was war da ein längster Druck? Keine Ahnung, fünf, sechs Stunden. Ich druck ja meistens nur so kleine Gehäuse für Controllers aus oder irgendwas.
Ich hab noch nie was gedruckt, was irgendwie zwei Tage ging.
Das ist tatsächlich, das hat zumindest irgendwo nen Sinn, dieses Ding, ja.
Okay, okay, Battlewolf, wir gucken mal kurz.
Probier das mal alles, weil das kann man wahrscheinlich nicht richtig anklicken.
Okay, gucken wir uns das mal kurz an.
Oh, bisschen groß, was ist denn so groß, die Seite?
What the fuck? Ah, weil's mobile ist.
Okay. EU-Stecker.
Das sieht noch aus wie ein Alter, da steht, da seh ich jetzt noch nix von, von irgendwie MediaTek.
Wichtig ist, wo steht da drauf, was Dremel ist? Die haben doch meistens so ein...
Specifications.
Ah, ist ja gut.
Zeig doch mal Specifications.
Ah, gibt's nicht, excellent.
Steht da irgendwas drin, was da...
Nee.
Was für ein Ding.
Steuerpflichtige Spannung.
Aha, alles klar.
Nee, da kann man sich leider keine Reim drauf machen.
Ich vermute mal, wenn's von, also ich würd jetzt mal vermuten, dass es wirklich noch ein ESP-266 ist, weil die Chinesen mögen die CPU oder den Controller einfach zu gern.
Also ich würd mal drauf tippen, mit dem geht's noch.
Da stand was mit das Motor, ja, aber das kann ja sein, dass das unterschiedliche Versionen gibt, hier unterschiedliche Versionen verschicken.
Aber das ist cool. Also das Ding ist wirklich cool, das würde ich, aber ganz ehrlich, da bist du ja 40 Stunden am Drucken.
Also ob sich dafür lohnt und ich so viele Dremel-Teile hab ich gar nicht. Ich krieg da vielleicht so ein paar Dinger hier voll und gut ist.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
What's on my face. Stimmt, das wird mich echt mal interessieren.
Heckermann.
Echt?
Der kann seinen Text davon ablesen, das ist natürlich big brain.
What the fuck? Ernsthaft? Das ist doch fake, oder?
Das ist ja poggers.
So was brauch ich auch.
Wann machst du das im Stream?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber genau, Google Class mit Twitch Chat, das braucht man, da hat die Welt drauf gewartet.
Keck weh im Auge, genau.
Okay, komm mal zum Punkt.
Mein Sonne, ich steil ich, sieht es jetzt ja nett aus, aber es ist eine coole Sache.
Renn auf alleinnen, wenn unsere Aufmerksamkeit nicht passt.
ETF
I stripped the display modules out of the headset and I ground away the mounting tabs.
I pulled the driver module out of the right side and hooked it up to the display module on the left side.
That's because the motion sensors are on the right side and the blind button is on the dominant.
I designed and printed a new monocular enclosure, then mounted it to a pair of cheapo glasses frames and cut off the excess.
I pulled the camera out and I threw it in the trash because the picture quality is so bad it wasn't even worth building it into the model.
I rooted the Android, I sideloaded Google services and I used...
Wo ist denn das Android drauf?
...the UI for wearable use.
I removed the onboard GPS chip antenna and hacked in a powered UFL port, then hooked it up to a shoulder mount...
Oder nee, das ist Übertragung von was anderem.
...those last mods were important because I built this thing to play Ingress, the inscrutable sci-fi predecessor to Pokemon Go.
I even put the Enlighten logo on this side.
Death to Smurfs. Ingress aggressively refused to run on the Moverium.
It took a lot of massaging, but I was able to get Ingress running on this thing and I got photographic evidence.
Unfortunately Ingress is unplayable these days, even on devices that are more capable, and as much as I'd love to pour some bursters out for my homies, the Google gods decree is absolute.
Side story, I continued to play Ingress and I met my wife through it.
The Optigon was kind of useless, but still comfortable enough to wear all day, so it became like a fashion accessory and a conversation piece that I could wear to meetups and hackercons.
The Optigon lay in its case, sad, lonely and out of battery. That was until September 2020.
I was serious about the whole YouTube thing, but I could barely remember in a material...
And that was my big brain idea. Your Android display self-wrapped and used as a prompter.
I'm a worm! A cybernetic worm!
So before we filmed the wire circuits on boards video, I took my script and I loaded it into the elegant teleprompter app.
We filmed that episode twice as fast as the previous two, and the Optigon has been a crucial part of my career ever since.
I will always say the same thing.
The place in my heart for head-mounted displays, and now that I need teleprompting, a display will always have a special place mounted to my head.
But this ain't over. The Optigon looks like it was half-assedly designed in a drunken weekend on SketchUp by an idiot and made on a ten-year-old printer, because that's exactly how it went down.
My viewers deserve better than this blocky geometry and tacky tribal team tattoos.
Oh, it's project time! First step was to hunt down the design files...
Switch to PETG...
Ob das jetzt besser aussieht als vorher?
Ey, aber auf jeden Fall massive big brain-Idee. Richtig, richtig huge.
So, ähm...
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Five smart home devices unter 30€. Okay, das ist was für mich.
This is Reid. Do you think it's true that you get what you pay for?
Das ist quasi Google Class für Arme, ja. Aber...
Äh, wahrscheinlich eine ganze Ecke nützlicher als Google Class.
Hat irgendwas an meinem Mikrofon wieder rumgestellt?
Nö.
Four in the smart home. I've been using a mix of inexpensive and expensive devices around my home for some time.
And I thought it would be interesting to take five devices under 30$ and compare...
Okay, typische NA-Switch.
Funktioniert hier gar nicht. Kriegste nicht in die Wand.
Ist Google... Ich glaub Google Class ist mal in so einer...
...Preview-Version erschienen und so und danach haben sie es eingestellt.
Das Einzige, was ich mir von Google Class gemerkt habe, ehrlich gesagt...
...ist, dass die Google Class, frag mich nicht was das war, Chef... Chefin oder so...
...äh, fremdgegangen ist mit einem der Google Chefs...
...und daraufhin sich die Frau vom Google Chef irgendwie hat scheiden lassen oder so.
Das ist irgendwie das Einzige, was hängen geblieben ist von Google Class, Alter.
Oh nee. Die... Von denen kommt mir nix mehr ins Haus.
Zumindest nicht mit der offiziellen Anbindung.
Das sind die... Das sind die, äh, die...
...die Zugänge zu den Kameras-Streams auf wegen einem China-Server hatten.
Da war doch wieder was die Tage... Ja, es ist laufend irgendwelche Leak-Geschichten, laufend.
Es versteht keine Woche, wo nicht irgendwie tausende, Millionen, hunderte, tausende, keine Ahnung...
...Daten irgendwo geleakt werden, weil es wieder Leute verkackt haben.
Deswegen ist die beste Sache einfach die Daten nicht speichern.
Dann kann man sie auch nicht verlieren.
Aber das ist ja überhaupt nicht angesagt.
Deswegen traue ich ja auch keinem, der sagt, wir sammeln die Daten...
...oder wir speichern die Daten in einem hoch-securen zentralen Rechenzentrum ab.
Die kriegen das eh nicht gebacken.
Und warum nicht so Regierungssachen?
Also sei es jetzt irgendwelche Krankenakten und so.
Diese Krankenakten-Sachen sind übrigens auch, ähm, fragwürdig.
Da gab es auch schon mal beim CC10-Vortrag zu.
Skeptisch gegenüberstehe ist Folgendes.
Das Erste, ich traue denen nicht zu, die Sachen wirklich sicher und ordentlich zu speichern.
So.
Das eigentliche Problem, was ich aber sehe, ist...
...dass man jetzt schon wiederholt gesehen hat, dass Dinge, die versprochen wurden, nicht gemacht wurden...
...oder aufgehoben wurden.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Sachen mit Corona-Daten, die erfasst werden, wer in welchem Restaurant war...
...dass die rein zweckgebunden für Corona-Zwecke sind.
Da fangen sie in Bayern jetzt ja schon wieder an.
So nach dem Motto, die Polizei soll zu tun sein.
Also sprich, dass man mit irgendwie einer Sache anfängt...
...und das dann im Laufe der Jahre, ohne dass das die Leute wirklich mitbekommen...
...total unterwandert und umwurstet.
Deswegen bin ich da extrem skeptisch, wenn bei irgendwelchen Digitalisierungsprojekten von unserer Regierung.
Zumal es ja mittlerweile eh egal ist, es glaubt ihnen ja eh keiner irgendwas mehr.
Also kann man auch machen, was man will.
Ich meine, so viele Dinge, wie da erzählt wurden, die gemacht werden oder nicht gemacht werden...
...und dann doch gemacht wurden, ist ja der Witz.
Und das letzte war ja diese Geschichte mit...
Welche Artikel war das nochmal? Artikel 19?
Nee, keine Ahnung. Die ganze Copyright-Geschichte, wo ja wirklich das, was keiner wollte...
...außer die Stonks-Industrie-Leute, wo man dann gedacht haben...
...oder Artikel 13, Artikel 17, weiß ich nicht, wo man dann das doch irgendwie durchgewurstet hat...
...weil irgendwelche Stonks-Leute das haben wollten.
Nee, aber der Witz ist halt, wenn man sagt, sowas ist zweckgebunden.
Und man weicht das dann einen Monat später wieder auf.
Da büßt man halt extrem an Glaubwürdigkeit ein.
Und das ist bei mir mittlerweile schon so weit, dass ich da halt prinzipiell nichts glaube, was gesagt wird.
Und meistens habe ich ja sogar Recht.
Diese ganze Geschichte, mir war von Anfang an klar, als sie gesagt haben, dass Corona-Lockdown nur November ist.
Jedem, der noch halbwegs normal im Kopf ist, muss eigentlich klar gewesen sein...
...dass diese Sache mit nur November rein vorgeschoben war, dass sich nicht noch mehr Leute aufregen.
Ich mag es aber nicht, wenn man mir absichtlich Mist erzählt, um mich zu beruhigen.
Das geht mir auf den Sack.
Es war klar, dass das verlängert wird.
Hätte man von Anfang an ehrlich gesagt, okay, wir machen das so lang, bis die Zahlen das erlauben, dass man das lockert.
Okay, da hätte ich ja mit leben können.
Das wäre übrigens eine klare Aussage gewesen.
Aber nicht diese Rumgewurst und Salamigetaktik immer.
Sagt mir einfach, was Sache ist.
Ja, das, das, das nervt mich.
Wenn ich absichtlich Mist erzählt bekomme, von dem ich schon weiß, dass er nicht stimmt.
Jetzt hab ich gar nicht geguckt, wo wir waren.
SmartThings ist auch so ein Ding, was mir nie ins Haus käme.
Nö, das hat man nicht gesagt.
Das hat man nicht gesagt.
Man hat gesagt, man macht jetzt erst mal nur November und man setzt sich Mitte November neu zusammen, um da noch irgendwelche Sachen zu klären.
Man hat sich Mitte November zusammengesetzt und absolut gar nichts gemacht und überlegt sich jetzt, ob man sich für 20. Dezember ausdehnt.
Aber das war ja von Anfang an klar.
Aber die haben so November November in Vordergrund gestellt, obwohl klar war, dass es nicht nur November ist.
Übrigens ist es auch noch eine Sache, die mir persönlich auch extrem auf den Sack geht, dass man quasi ein halbes Jahr Zeit hatte.
Ich meine, die hatten jetzt quasi den Sommer über Zeit, sich Dinge zu überlegen, wie man Sachen handeln kann.
Aber trotzdem wirkt es jetzt an vielen Stellen einfach total wie übers Knie gebrochen.
Ja, was hat man dann die letzten sechs Monate gemacht?
Jetzt überlegen sich so Sachen wie, ja, können wir Unterricht nicht mehr remote machen, können wir Unterricht nicht in Tourenhallen, Museen, sonst wie machen.
Warum hat man sich das denn nicht die letzten sechs Monate mal überlegt?
Warum hat man sich nicht die letzten sechs Monate mal überlegt?
Okay, was machen wir, wenn das wieder soweit kommt?
Ich meine, das war ja nicht so, als war das jetzt unerwartet, dass das im Winter wieder losgeht.
Und jetzt hat man sich hingesetzt und dachte, ha, wir brauchen jetzt ganz schnell irgendeine Eilssitzung oder hier ganz schnell müssen wir uns irgendwas überlegen.
Warum eigentlich hat man die letzten sechs Monate da gesessen und gehofft, es passiert nichts?
Das war nicht im Budget drinne. Tja, zu wenig Stonks.
Es gibt, ja, ich weiß nicht, ich bin da nicht, also ich bin überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit, wie das gehandelt wird.
Auch, dass vieles nicht wirklich nachvollziehbar ist, dann haben wir noch die Sache, dass du teilweise nicht genau weißt, was jetzt bei dir ist.
Zum Beispiel darfst du, ob du Tennis spielen darfst, ist nicht so klar.
Kommt auf das Bundesland an.
Ich glaube, ganz verboten ist es mittlerweile in keinem Bundesland. Ich glaube, es gibt Bundesländer, wo die Entscheidung noch aussteht.
Es gibt Bundesländer, da darfst du in der Halle. Es gibt welche, da darfst du irgendwie nicht in der Halle, nur draußen.
Und das ist, aah.
Ja, und was auch der Witz ist, ein Kollege von mir hat eine Tochter in Kolumbien, ich glaube, war das.
Und wisst ihr, was die machen? Die machen Remote-Unterricht in der Schule. Und was machen wir? Lüftungsdienst.
Ich meine, Kolumbien kriegt das besser hin.
Also, gut, ich kenne mich jetzt nicht so mit dem aktuellen Entwicklungsstand von Kolumbien aus, aber ich würde mal, zumindest aus dem Bauch raus sagen,
die haben nicht so das Geld und nicht so die Technik wie wir.
Hätte ich jetzt mal vermutet, aber anscheinend ist es ja nicht so, anscheinend ist diese Vermutung ja falsch, weil Kolumbien kriegt das hin.
Und wir nicht. Und was machen wir? Wir machen Pläne, wer jetzt Tafel wischen muss und wer lüften muss. Jaja.
Ich glaube einfach, wir können solche modernen Sachen nicht richtig.
Das liegt aber, ich finde, man kann das nicht alles so auf die Regierung schieben, wobei das sicherlich einen ganz großen Teil zu beiträgt,
weil man müsste ja auch dafür sorgen, dass die Bevölkerung generell ein bisschen weniger technikfeindlich ist.
Kann man ja machen, könnte man in irgendeiner Art und Weise fördern, dass die Leute sich da mehr zutrauen und so.
Aber wir sind in Deutschland doch relativ technikfeindlich.
Das habe ich schon gemerkt. Gerade die Leute, die jetzt vielleicht nicht die Summergeneration sind, aber Leute in meinem Alter und älter,
wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt auch 36, aber ich bin ja schon, ich bin ja quasi so die erste Generation, die so richtig mit Computerkram und Konsolenkram aufgewachsen ist.
Und, aber selbst in meinem Alter schon, es gibt sehr viele Leute, die sind so ultra technikfeindlich in Deutschland. Ich verstehe das gar nicht.
Ich bin 36, ja, ich bin, äh, tja, das glauben die Leute immer nicht. Ich sitze, ich bin 36, ich sitze sonntags vormittags vor meinem Rechner und sage Poggers und Postchamp.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Google Street View ist auch so ein schönes Beispiel. Google Street View ist auch ein schönes Beispiel.
Überall auf der Welt kannst du einfach mal in Google gucken und kannst dir dann anschauen, wie sehen die Straßen aus.
Nicht so in Deutschland, weil wir damals so einen riesen Shitstorm da losgetreten haben, weil Google irgendwelche Hauswender gezeigt hat in Google Maps.
Tja, und dann hat Google gesagt, wisst ihr was, ihr könnt uns mal, wir fahren einfach in Deutschland nicht mehr rum.
Ich dachte, du bist Mitte 20, ich war Mitte 20, als ich mit YouTube Sachen angefangen habe.
Ja, aber mit so Technik Sachen haben wir es hier eh nicht so ganz. Und ich sage euch, das wird noch richtig Probleme geben die nächsten Jahre.
Weil viele zu dieser, was ist denn das hier rechts eigentlich? Chat, wart ihr das?
Weil viele zu dieser klassischen Berufe ist eh fragwürdig, ob es das in Zukunft noch geben wird.
Also viele Berufe, wo manuell Sachen gemacht werden, also die den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Akten sortieren und rumdingsen und stempeln und irgendwelche Buchhaltungssachen vielleicht.
So viele dieser klassischen Bürojobs, aber auch viele dieser klassischen, ja so Sachen wie, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Leute im Bergwerk oder auch viele Sachen am Fließband.
Das wird es in Zukunft so nicht mehr geben. Das ist ja jetzt schon, das fängt ja jetzt gerade richtig an, dass das ganz viele Sachen quasi in der letzten Generation sind, wenn du es so willst.
Viele dieser Sachen werden in Zukunft nicht mehr neu besetzt, weil das brauchst du nicht mehr.
Es gibt Sachen, die brauchst du weiterhin, also du brauchst weiterhin sowas wie Klempner oder die klassischen Handwerker, die dir auch mal einen Dach decken können und sowas.
Ja klar, das braucht man auf jeden Fall noch, aber so Leute, die am Fließband was arbeiten oder Leute, die im Bergwerk arbeiten, das wird immer weniger und ganz viele Buchsachen wird es so in Zukunft nicht mehr geben.
Und ich sehe da überhaupt nicht, dass da irgendwie die Weichen gestellt werden in Zukunft.
Also gar nicht, gar nicht, außer dass die meisten, also dass ein Großteil der deutschen Bevölkerung irgendwie übelst technikfeindlich ist.
Keine Ahnung. Zum Beispiel auch eine Sache, wo ich mich frage, warum wir da...
Ich meine, ich muss da anders anfangen. Wie haben wir weder krasse Rohstoffe in Deutschland, noch haben wir irgendwie andere super tolle Sachen, die man verkaufen kann.
Also sprich, unsere Grundlage ist ja eigentlich, dass wir modern sind, dass wir gut ausgebildete Leute haben, dass wir Jahrzehnte, Jahrhunderte langes Know-how aufgebaut haben und dass wir halt einfach Sachen machen können, die andere nicht machen können.
Also jetzt nicht, wir können kein Gold verkaufen, wir können keine Kohle verkaufen, kein Silber, kein sonst was.
Wir sind quasi, wir sind quasi big brain. Also wenn wir nicht mehr big brain sind, dann haben wir gelitten.
Da können wir es nur noch machen, wie die Chinesen aktuell, wir können vielleicht ganz gute Sachen möglichst billig herstellen.
Aber eigentlich müssten wir viel mehr big brain sein und auch in zukunftsträchtigen Sachen big brain sein.
Zum Beispiel sowas wie Fleisch herstellen im Labor. Das ist so ein Ding, das nehme ich dann immer als Beispiel ganz gern, weil es auch ein Thema ist, was mich wirklich interessiert.
Weil ich bin jemand, mir sagt diese ganze Veganer-Geschichte nicht zu.
Allerdings, ich finde, wie die Tiere gehalten werden und dieses ganze Verarbeitungssystem auch nicht gut.
Also mir persönlich wäre es am liebsten, ich könnte Fleisch essen, aber ohne dass man Tiere dafür umbringen muss.
So und deswegen fände ich es super, wenn man einfach Fleisch bekommen würde, was Fleisch ist, aber wofür keine Tiere sterben müssen.
Wäre top und ich bin da ziemlich zuversichtlich, dass das ein Markt für die Zukunft oder generell ein Technologiefeld ist, was sehr zukunftsträchtig ist.
Künstliches Fleisch herstellen. Und das wird PC-lustig, ich denke auch, dass das auf jeden Fall kommen wird.
Ne, umbringen, wie würdest du das sonst nennen? Du hast eine Kuh, die lebt und du schießt dir was in den Kopf und dann ist sie tot.
Also das kannst du ja nicht anders als umbringen nennen, oder? Was soll denn das sonst sein?
Also das muss man auch nicht, das muss man ja nicht, kann man ja nicht irgendwie beschönen oder so.
Das finde ich nicht gut, aber ich will trotzdem Fleisch essen.
Und ich glaube, das ist echt eine zukunftsrechtige Sache, wo wir halt gar nichts wirklich machen.
Klar würde ich, wo ist denn der Unterschied, ob du ein künstliches Schnitzel isst, ob du jetzt künstliches Muskelfleisch, ob du jetzt künstliches Kuhmuskelfleisch oder Kuhmuskelfleisch nimmst.
Also Muskelfleisch ist ja Muskelfleisch, das ist ja erstmal kein großer Unterschied. Natürlich braucht die Technik noch ein bisschen und der Aufwand ist auch noch ziemlich hoch, ja das stimmt.
Aber ich glaube zumindest, man weiß, nachher bist du immer schlauer, ich glaube wir werden da auch über kurz oder lang zumindest weltweit nicht herum kommen.
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass gerade China und Indien, oder generell so asiatische Länder, aber hauptsächlich China und Indien, dass es denen ja auch jetzt immer besser geht und dort auch der Lebensstandard steigt und gerade in China viel mehr Leute Fleisch futtern, wie sie es früher gemacht haben.
Das war ja früher zum größten Teil halt Reis, Gemüse, bisschen Fleisch und die essen immer mehr Fleisch. Die Frage ist ja, wo kommt und wo soll denn der ganze Kram herkommen?
Du kannst ja schlecht Schafe auf dem Mond züchten oder sowas. Irgendwie musst du den Kram ja versorgen. Und ich glaube zumindest, dass Fleisch aus dem Labor uns da helfen könnte und das ist auch so was, wo ich mich frage, warum machen wir da nicht mehr in dieser Richtung?
Wir hätten doch jetzt die Chance uns da Know-how und Skills aufzubauen, dass wir sowas gut können, weil das wäre zum Beispiel was Zukunftsträchtiges.
Aber wie gesagt, mit so Zukunftssachen haben wir es nicht so. Wir überlegen uns eher, ob man nicht noch irgendwelche Kohlebergwerke neu baut oder sowas.
Ja, genau und deswegen muss man da forschen und gucken, wie man das am besten machen kann.
Es gibt noch zig andere solche Beispiele, wo ich mich frage, warum? Ich meine, der Internetausbau in Deutschland ist ja wohl das beste Beispiel für.
Also ich meine, so beschissen wie bei uns und planlos läuft es ja fast nirgendwo anders, was Internetausbau angeht.
Und das ist auch mein Problem. Es gibt ehrlich gesagt keine Partei, von denen ich irgendwie sinnvolle Zukunftsvisionen höre.
Das höchste der Gefühle ist, dass du irgendeinen Typ hast, der sich hinstellt und sagt, ja 2045 ist es dann so weit.
Aber kein Plan, wie man da hinkommt, keine einzelnen Schritte, kein Gesamtbild oder irgendwas.
Also insofern habe ich dementsprechend auch immer noch keine Ahnung, was ich wählen soll.
Außer die Partei. Nee, keine Ahnung. Ich habe früher mal die Piraten gewählt, als die neu waren.
Aber die haben sich ja selbst aufgelöst, selbst zersetzt in Deutschland.
Naja. Zumindest ich denke nicht, dass wir bereit sind für die Zukunft, was da auf uns zukommt.
Ich sehe auch nicht, dass da irgendwie unsere Regierung da die Weichen für stellen würde.
Es ist eigentlich doof, dass es da gar nicht so viele Unterschiede gibt.
Ich fände es viel besser, wenn die wirklich jeder was voll Gegensätzliches als Zukunftsvision hätten.
Weil dann könnte man immerhin auch sagen, okay, das ist jetzt was, was ich gut finde, das ist was, was ich mir realistisch vorstellen kann, das ist was, was ich nicht so...
Dann könnte ich mir da irgendwas raussuchen. Aber so ist das eigentlich kaum ein Unterschied.
Es macht kaum ein Unterschied. Und man sieht es auch in Hessen. Wir haben sogar einen grünen Umweltminister.
Und die sind damals mit angetreten. So nach dem Motto, hey, das ist übrigens was, wo ich nicht für bin.
Weil ich sage nur, mit was die angetreten sind. Komplettes, striktes Nachtflugverbot, Flughafen Frankfurt, kein Ausbau Frankfurt und auch zig andere Dinger.
So und was ist das erste, was gemacht wurde, wo wir mit dem grünen Umweltminister in Hessen kein Nachtflugverbot und Frankfurter Flughafen ausgebaut haben.
Was ich persönlich gut finde, weil ich finde Frankfurter Flughafen ist wichtig für Frankfurt.
Aber da sieht man mal so, hey, man kann viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Wenn man dann mal in der Position ist, wo man darüber entscheiden muss, dann sieht die Sache wieder ganz anders aus.
Tja.
Aktuell sieht es für mich eher so aus, als versuchen alle es so vielen wie möglich...
Ne, umgedreht. Sie versuchen es nicht so vielen wie möglich recht zu machen. Sie versuchen es bei so vielen wie möglich nicht anzuecken.
So und was da rauskommt, ist halt zumindest mein Eindruck, dass das alles so ein riesen Haufen profilloser Leute, profilloser Dinge ist.
Und dementsprechend habe ich keine Ahnung, was ich wählen soll.
Naja, dauert ja noch. Nächstes Jahr ist ja erst so weit, ne.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich wieder ungültig wählen, weil ich echt keine Ahnung habe, was ich machen soll.
Sinnvoll, dass es einmal dahingestellt, aber es gibt halt nichts, was ich wählen will.
Wir machen wieder den Wahl-O-Mat vorher. Und da kommt dann wahrscheinlich wieder raus.
Das letzte Mal war witzig. Das letzte Mal, wo wir Wahl-O-Mat gemacht haben, für die Europawahl war das, da kam raus, ich soll die Partei wählen.
Kam wirklich raus beim Wahl-O-Mat. Ich soll die Partei wählen, gefolgt von der AfD.
Und danach irgendwie total abgeschlagen. Frag mich nicht, die Grünen und die CDU und sowas.
Ich hatte irgendwie, ich hatte irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 78% Übereinstimmung glaubt mit, mit, mit die Partei.
Irgendwie frag mich nicht, 70 mit der AfD. Und dann irgendwie, dann kam irgendwie mit 50 die CDU oder sowas.
Wir machen dann wieder, wir machen dann wieder den Wahl-O-Mat.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was rauskommt. Ja, ich glaube 2021 sind.
Ich glaube, ich sehe halt einfach nicht, dass wir uns zukunftsträchtig oder zukunftsfähig aufstellen.
Und die nächsten Jahre wird das noch richtig hart, ja.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass einige, wie gesagt, der Arbeitsplätze, die es jetzt gibt und auch der Job,
die es jetzt gibt, dass es die so gar nicht mehr geben wird. Klar, gibt es auch neue.
Aber wie ich gerade, wie ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, es gibt einfach viele Sachen, die brauchst du nicht mehr.
Und dann, dann will ich mal sehen, wie das jetzt funktionieren soll. Ich meine, sowohl Kranken, das unser Gesundheitssystem,
als auch die Rentengeschichte, sowas, das funktioniert ja jetzt schon nicht mehr wirklich.
Wie soll das das erst funktionieren, wenn es dann viele Jobs gar nicht mehr gibt?
Die Tierschutzpartei, ja, da habe ich auch schon mal drüber nachgedacht.
Was, du hättest gern jemand, der dir sagt, dass du die Grünen wählen sollst? Hä? Hä?
Ich habe allgemein nicht gern, wenn mir jemand sagt, was ich machen soll.
Was auch der Grund ist, warum mir das Fernsehprogramm bei der ARD so auf den Sack geht.
Wenn ich da mal ab und zu was gucke.
Weil die sagen dir nicht, wie es ist auf der Welt, die sagen dir, was du davon denken sollst, was auf der Welt ist.
Was meiner Meinung nach nicht die Aufgabe eines öffentlich-rechtlichen Senders ist.
Tja, aber letztendlich, Leute, es macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Wie gesagt, die, die jetzt groß tönen, dass sie alles anders machen würden, werden es nicht tun, wenn sie in die Regierung kommen.
Und von denen, die überhaupt die Chance haben, da reinzukommen, von denen ist alles irgendwie so ultra-unverschämt.
Und von denen, die überhaupt die Chance haben, da reinzukommen, von denen ist alles irgendwie so ultra-profil-los.
Und ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich da wähle.
Naja, ist halt voll im Arsch.
Deswegen mein persönliches Fazit aus den letzten Jahren auch.
Was ich gelernt habe ist, man muss nicht darauf warten, dass irgendjemand mal politisch was im eigenen Interesse macht.
Also ich kann mich weder darauf verlassen, noch muss ich darauf warten, dass irgendjemand quasi was umsetzt, was für mich mal was bringt.
Dementsprechend ist mein Fazit, die letzten 20 Jahre, seitdem ich mir das so ein bisschen angucke.
Das Einzige, was man machen kann, ist egoistisch sein.
So doof es klingt und so scheiße ich das finde, aber man sieht das auch.
Nicht nur in Deutschland, man sieht das auch weltweit, dass die Leute immer egoistischer werden.
Aber woher kommt das denn?
Das kommt hauptsächlich auch daran, weil man sieht, okay, das Einzige, worauf man sich verlassen kann, ist, dass man sich auf sich selbst verlassen kann.
Das war nicht gut, das war in der Familie mal außen vor, aber dass man sieht, es hat keinen Einfluss, was ich mache.
Und ich kann eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass nichts in meinem Interesse gemacht wird.
Also das Einzige, was unterm Strich übrig bleibt, ist, dass die Leute egoistischer werden.
Das war, wie gesagt, ich finde es auch nicht schön, aber es ist leider das Einzige, was unterm Strich übrig bleibt.
Naja, egal, wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
So, wir schauen uns jetzt noch mal weiter hier an, was es für Smart Home Tech gibt für unter 30 Euro.
Ich könnte mit diesem Thema noch ewig weitermachen.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich Twitter und so mir nicht mehr geben kann auf Deutsch gestellt, sondern wie gesagt, ich habe mein Twitter auf Andorra gestellt,
weil es eigentlich keiner Gruppierung, oder ich musste jetzt gar keine erwähnen, es gibt ja viele Gruppchen, die sich auch unter anderem nicht leiden können und so,
weil es keiner Gruppierung, die es so gibt, darum geht wirklich so die Welt irgendwie besser zu machen,
sondern eigentlich allen nur darum geht, sich gegenseitig zu bestätigen, dass sie die besseren Menschen sind.
Dabei ist ja der Witz eigentlich, die Menschheit hat es ja eigentlich nur so lange geschafft, weil sie nur so weit geschafft,
sie haben nur das, meiner Meinung nach, was wir jetzt haben und auch an Technologie und alles, weil die Menschheit miteinander geredet hat,
Sachen aufgeschrieben haben, sich untereinander geholfen hat und ja hauptsächlich miteinander geredet hat und das ist das Gegenteil von dem, was wir gerade machen.
Es geht nur noch darum, sich selbst zu bestätigen, dass man selbst der beste Mensch ist und alle anderen scheiße.
Deswegen kann ich mir Twitter nicht mehr geben.
In der Regel musst du da irgendwelche Kompromisse finden für alle Seiten, aber deswegen kann ich mir Twitter nicht mehr geben.
Und Twitter ist eh ganz, ganz schrecklich mittlerweile, was das angeht.
Ich kann mir, was mich auch immer, übrigens witzig, weißt du was, gestern auf Twitter muss ich mal was steamen, das wollte ich euch mal zeigen.
Wo so finde ich Weltverbesserungs-Sachen voll in die falsche Richtung laufen.
Was ich meine ist, egal wie lange eine Diskussion im Internet geht, irgendwann bringt einer Hitler als Vergleich.
Immer.
Es ist egal wie lange, ihr werdet immer.
Man sollte schon das Ziel haben, ich meine klar ist Weltverbesserung abstrakt.
Und ich fände es auch gut, wenn nicht jeder nur an sich denken würde, aber aktuell machen wir halt das Gegenteil.
Wir bringen den Leuten quasi noch bei, sie müssen an sich selbst denken.
Aber klar, was soll dann auch sonst passieren, wenn das so läuft.
Genau, was ich bei Steam zeigen wollte, was ich gestern übelst lustig fand, hier das da.
Wo sie wieder versuchen die Welt zu verbessern, ich wusste erst gar nicht was das ist, ich hab das als Werbung bekommen.
Das LatinX Game Festival, wisst ihr was ich ernsthaft gedacht hab?
Ich hab gedacht, das ist irgendeine japanische Videoserie, die halt LatinX heißt.
Irgendein was weiß ich, Graphic Novel oder sowas.
Bis ich dann festgestellt hab, ey, das ist die Schreibweise für Latino und Latina.
Also die korrekte Schreibweise für Latino und Latina.
So und der Witz ist dabei jetzt allerdings, dass, also quasi Südamerikaner, Latinamericans, wie auch immer man es nennt,
dass die sich dadurch beleidigt fühlen, das fand ich witzig.
Nach dem Motto, man versucht es besonders korrekt zu machen und die Leute, die man quasi beschützen möchte mit dieser besonderen Korrektheit,
fühlen sich dadurch beleidigt.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht aufmachen, weil das ist bestimmt Monka Toss, was es da als Antwort gibt.
Und das finde ich, das fand ich gestern schon irgendwie ein bisschen lustig.
Also wenn es schon wieder nach hinten losgeht, weil man übertrieben korrekt sein will.
Knäbär, ich wusste, dass das kommt, dieses Bild.
Ich wusste, dass das kommt.
Ihr müsst euch mal die Antworten durchlesen.
Es ist auch total viel auf Spanisch und Portugiesisch, wo sie sich halt darüber lustig machen.
Es ist, naja.
Und ja, das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich da an sich bin.
Da geht so viel Energie aktuell drauf in diese Richtung.
Diese Energie wäre meiner Ansicht nach zumindest in anderen Bereichen besser aufgehoben.
Aber das fand ich lustig gestern.
Man versucht besonders korrekt zu sein und gerade die, weshalb man besonders korrekt sein will, sagen, halt die Klappe.
Ich fand es ja auch letztens, weiß ich, ob ich schon...
Wie gesagt, neben mir wohnt eine türkische Familie, die sind gerade dabei ihr Haus umzubauen.
Und die haben halt hauptsächlich türkische Handwerker.
Kann ich auch irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Kannst du easy mit denen reden und wahrscheinlich ist es auch der Cousin vom Cousin oder sowas.
Würde ich auch so machen.
Dann war ich letztens beim Italiener am Start.
Die haben umgebaut, habe ich mir einen Schnitzel geholt, habe ich einen Schnitzel bestellt.
Beim Italiener am Start, die haben gerade umgebaut, weil sie coronamäßig eh nicht aufmachen können.
Und italienische Handwerker am Start.
Alles vollkommen nachvollziehbar.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal, wie krass die Leute empört wären auf Twitter.
Würde ich sagen, ich habe mir Handwerker bestellt, aber nur deutsche.
Alter, die würden ausrasten.
Die würden komplett, mache ich nicht.
Aber wenn ich das schreiben würde, ehrlich gesagt, ist mir das ziemlich wurscht, solange die gute Arbeit machen.
Und ich mit denen auf normalem Deutsch kommunizieren kann, ist mir das ziemlich wurscht.
Aber Twitter wird ausrasten.
Twitter würde ausrasten, Alter.
Da wird dann wahrscheinlich Hashtag Nazi-Keks oder sowas kommen gleich.
Ich kann es mir richtig vorstellen.
Twitter rastet immer aus, deswegen kann ich mir Twitter nicht mehr geben.
Ja, und das ist generell was, was mir bei der aktuellen Entwicklung voll auf den Sack geht.
Dass es viel weniger um das geht, um die Aussage geht oder um den Inhalt geht, was jemand von sich gibt.
Sondern nur, ob das irgendwie Raum dafür bietet, dass man sich darüber aufregen kann.
Ich glaube, wir wären doch besser beraten, wenn man sich über Probleme normal austauschen könnte
und auch problematische Sachen ansprechen könnte, als quasi alles umschiffen zu müssen permanent.
Weil das ist unglaublich schwierig.
Irgendwann sagst du mal was Verkehrtes und dann sind sie alle wieder dabei, sich aufzuregen.
Und du bist gleich der allerschlimmste Mensch auf der Welt.
Schlimmer als, was, funktioniert eigentlich deine Raspberry Pi USB noch?
Ja, die funktioniert noch. Die geht noch.
Du meinst dieses Teil mit der Batterie drin. Ja, die funktioniert noch.
Du meinst das Ding. Die funktioniert sogar ganz gut.
So, äh, USB.
PS. Genau das Ding, weil das ist richtig poggers, ich weiß nur nicht.
Das sieht so ähnlich aus wie die, aber ist es nicht.
Das ist wirklich nice. Ich find's bloß nicht.
Da hab ich mir nämlich mal zum 10er Pack von bestellt.
Ihr kennt mich ja, ich bestell mir immer nur 10er Packs oder 3, 5 oder 10.
Wo hat der das?
Der hat das doch mal in einem Video vorgestellt.
Hier, 10 battery powered boards for Raspberry Pi.
Das ist richtig geil, das Teil. Also das würd ich mir wieder kaufen.
USB, 10 battery powered boards. Nee, nee, das ist schon länger her.
Alter Chat, was mit euch schon wieder los hier gerade?
Über was seid ihr euch eigentlich gerade am aufregen im Chat? Ich kapier's nicht.
Kappa Pride, ja.
Ich find's nicht.
Das Ding ist richtig nice. Jetzt wollte ich es euch gerade noch mal auf AliExpress zeigen.
UPS.
Das Ding, genau, das Ding.
Hat auch da einen Link dazu.
Exzellent, genau den da mein ich. Das Ding ist wirklich nice.
Da hab ich mir mal einen 10er Pack von bestellt.
Überlegt euch mal, überlegt euch mal Chat. Der Zentralrat der Kekse ist äußerst empört gerade über euch.
Also Chat.
Das ist nice das Ding. Man kann sich auch mit dem USB Kabel kaufen.
Dann kostet es ein paar Cent mehr.
Also man kann das mit USB Kabel für 2,17 kaufen.
Aber für 1,75 oder für 1,84, es gibt eben 5% Rabatt.
Man braucht aber noch eine Batterie für und da muss so eine 18655 Batterie rein.
Und dann kann man den Raspberry Pi mit betreiben so für, also ich hab nun ein Zero dran.
So 4-5 Stunden oder so sollte er halten, wenn er nicht volle Pulle läuft.
Void Danny Prime Sub. Danke schon für den Sub. Exzellent.
Big Brain Sub.
Ja das meine ich übrigens. Captain Fox Godwin's Law habe ich vorhin gemeint. Nicht Rule irgendwas.
Das habe ich gemeint. Ja genau.
Umso länger eine Diskussion im Internet geht, umso mehr steigt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass irgendwie einer einen Nazi Vergleich bringt. Ganz genau.
Das dauert nicht lang und gerade auf Reddit oder Twitter geht das ganz schnell.
Es wird bloß noch getoppt von Rule, was ist das? Rule 34.
Das ist zwar was ganz anderes, aber das stimmt auch.
Ich glaube Rule 34 ist, ich gebe das jetzt nicht ein. Ich gebe das jetzt nicht ein, weil das erste was du findest ist wahrscheinlich schon mal ganz, wer weiß was man da als Output kriegt.
Rule 34 ist, wenn es irgendwas gibt, dann gibt es auch Porn dazu. Und das ist ja nun wirklich nur Tatsache mittlerweile.
Nee nee Sebaro, das machen wir jetzt nicht auf.
So zumindest dieses Ding ist nice. Also wenn ihr einen Raspberry Pi habt und die Dinger, oder am besten einen Raspberry Pi Zero, normalen Raspberry Pi auch,
die Dinger neigen ja dazu, dass wenn der Strom einfach so mal ausgeht, dass die ganz gerne mal nicht mehr booten. Und das kann man der Sache gut hier mit vorbeugen.
Übrigens wenn ein Raspberry nicht bootet, ist das immer daran zu erkennen, dass es diese Copper Pride Regenbogenfarbe beim Booten hat. Rainbow Screen. Das da.
Also wenn der Raspberry den Copper Pride Screen zeigt, dann ist der Bootloader kaputt.
Das ist der Kirby Relaxing Music Playlist. Ich hoffe mal das ist kein Monka Toss.
So und das kann man vorbeugen, indem man an den Raspberry Pi so einen Board dran macht und so eine Batterie, ne Moment.
Aber Batterie, fuck, wie heißen die? 18, ah 650 waren es genau. Das sind so die gleichen Batterien, die auch in Akkus drin sind.
Oder die man auch in E-Zigaretten macht und sowas. Also die gleichen Zellen. Und damit läuft das so 3-4 Stunden.
Das reicht aber dicke, weil meistens ist der Strom bis dahin schon wieder da. Und der schaltet das auch automatisch.
Also sprich, ihr macht hier einen USB rein, auf der anderen Seite den Raspberry Pi dran, hier den Raspberry Pi dran, hier den Input.
Und er schaltet dann automatisch um, sobald kein Strom mehr durchkommt auf die Batterie. Eigentlich richtig gut.
Also, wenn ihr den Raspberry Pi bootet, dann zeigt er immer den Screen. Wenn der Bootloader kaputt ist, dann zeigt er nur noch diesen Screen.
Wenn man ganz genau sein will. Also wenn ihr den Raspberry Pi anmacht und ihr nur noch diesen Screen seht, dann bootet er nicht mehr, dann ist der Bootloader meistens kaputt.
Was hilft, ist die SD-Karte neu flaschen. Ein einfaches Checkdisk oder Mk, äh, Dings, ne, wie heißt es? FSDK ist glaube ich unter Windows, oder?
Oder war FSDK unter Linux? Reicht meistens nicht. Man muss das dann neu flaschen. Und das haben die Raspberry Pies ganz gerne mal, nachdem man einfach den Strom abzieht und nachdem der Strom ausgegangen ist.
Und da bringt das hier halt richtig gut was für. Ja. So, wo sind wir eigentlich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Mega Upload, oh ne, oh ne. Meint ihr, meint ihr der Mega Upload Song ist copyrighted?
Ich mein gerade, gerade er hat's ja so mit Copyright, ne?
Ja, die Batterie wird automatisch geladen, wenn Strom da ist. Das ist quasi wirklich ne Mini-USB.
Load, load, load. Use Mega Upload.
Überlegt euch mal, das ist schon 10 Jahre her wieder.
Das Beste. Ohne Mist, dass das was von Mega Upload bei mir bis heute im Kopf hängen geblieben ist, ist dieser komische Mega Upload Song.
Ansonsten nix. Der ist hängen geblieben.
Was ist mit der Steckdose aus dem letzten Stream passiert? Die funktioniert?
Ich weiß nicht, warst du nicht bis zum Schluss da? Aber die hat am Ende vom Stream funktioniert. Auf hier.
Am Ende haben wir die wieder zusammengebaut.
Nachdem ich es versucht habe die ganze Zeit falsch rum zuzumachen.
Dann haben wir sie zugemacht und ausprobiert. Ja gut, dass die 246 Volt nicht stimmen, ja.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, was es Mist stimmt, so halbwegs.
Man sieht ja, dass sie funktioniert. Man kann sie WLAN steuern, die ist jetzt an.
Hier ist das Web Interface, wo man sieht, dass es an ist.
Man sieht dann auch den Stromverbrauch irgendwann, wenn ich es einschalte.
Wie fandet ihr das mit der Kamera? Ich fand das mal frischer Wind für einen Stream.
Jetzt sieht man bei der Steckdose, USB-Charger, 6 Watt Verbrauch.
Also wie du siehst hat alles funktioniert. Wo ich mir halt echt schwer getan habe, ist am Anfang hier das aufzukriegen.
Guckt euch mal an. Das Ding ist übrigens RIP.
So, hier. Wie es nicht aufging.
Richtig schwer geworden. Wie es nicht funktioniert.
Du kannst sie kaufen, weil ich habe danach festgestellt, man hat vorne Schrauben, um die aufzumachen.
Ich hätte die gar nicht aufbrechen müssen.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was mein persönliches Highlight war im Stream?
Wie es verbogen ist.
Wie es nicht verbogen ist.
30 Geräte für unter 30 Dollar.
Was hältst du von IKEA Tratt Free? Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, aber ich weiß, was du meinst.
Kann man machen. Das ist Zigbee, gedönns glaube. Kann man machen.
Also was ich auf jeden Fall nie verwenden werde ist Philips Hue. Das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Das Zeug ist ultra teuer und die machen komische Dinger.
Zum Beispiel habe ich letztens auf Reddit gelesen, dass alte Philips Hue Hubs gepatcht wurden, dass sie nicht mehr funktionieren.
Oder in den Zustand gepatcht wurden, dass man sie nicht mehr ordentlich verwenden kann.
Ich glaube es geht los.
Wenn man die natürlich über Home Assistant einbindet, ist das wieder was anderes.
Deswegen ist es am besten, man verwendet sowas wie Home Assistant oder Open Hub, wenn man auf Java steht, als zentrale Steuerungssoftware.
Da kann man einfach alles mögliche einbinden und es muss nicht alles vom gleichen Hersteller sein.
Was sagst du zum Harmony Hub für TV und PS4 zum Einschalten?
Also um Fernseh und PS4 einzuschalten, da brauche ich doch kein Harmony Hub für.
Wenn du Infrarotgeräte einschalten willst, das beste, was du dir dafür holen kannst, ist das hier.
So was hier kostet einen Bruchteil von so einem Logitech Harmony Ding.
Kannst du mit Custom-Firmware oder zumindest mit Custom-Steuerungssoftware betreiben und sendet Infrarot-Signale für dich.
Eine andere Variante ist auch noch, um den Fernseh einzuschalten.
Ich glaube, man kann es flashen, aber zumindest gibt es eine Custom-Steuerungs-Firmware, ist über CEC.
Da brauchst du ein Gerät, das über HDMI die Sachen einschalten kann.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es gerade für die PS4 auch schon... Gibt es Kodi für die PS4?
Nee, oder? Aber Kodi für die Xbox One gibt es.
Gibt es Kodi für die PS... Official Kodi für die PS4?
Ultimate Guide. Über Plex. Das ist so ein richtiger Chebat-Artikel. So ein richtiger Chebat-Artikel wieder.
The Ultimate Guide of Installing Kodi on PS4. Und dann kriegst du als Antwort, Kodi ist currently not available für PS4.
Excellent. So muss das sein. Aber das Harmony-Zeug ist total overpriced.
Wenn du Infrarot-Sachen schicken willst, nimm das hier.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch eine gute Home Assistant-Integration in ProdLink.
Genau. RM-Mini, RM-Mini 3. Ich hab die hier. Ich hab die hier ein paar von.
Aber die hab ich auch schon seit zwei Jahren oder so. Da gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile neuere Sachen für.
Mit IO-Broker geht's garantiert auch, wenn's mit Home Assistant geht.
So. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die... Es gibt ja diese ProdLink Cloud-Geschichte, aber man kann das auch lokal bedienen.
Und ich musste das damals so machen. Ich hab versucht, meine Klimaanlage damit mal anzusteuern, bevor ich meine eigenen Klimaanlagen...
Wir haben ja sogar eine Klimaanlagen-Steuerung im Streamer programmiert für dieses Mitsubishi-Ding hier mit dem ESP32.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was wir dafür verwendet haben. Wir haben zwei Infrarot-LEDs und wir hatten ein Display für Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur.
Das war nur ein Luftfeuchtigkeits- und Temperatursensor und ein Infrarot-LED zum Steuern.
So.
Der Eingriff in die Steckdose stellt einen Verstoß gegen... Äh ja, sowas haben wir. Exzellent. Anzeige ist raus.
So. Und... Genau. Ich hab damals für diesen ProdLink Cloud das hier verwendet. Das gab's auf GitHub.
Und das ist eine Software, mit der man...
...mitschneiden kann...
...was für Geräte gerade was schicken über Funk.
Und so konnte ich damals meine Klimaanlage diesem ProdLink beibringen, was für ein Infrarot-Signal er für die Klimaanlage schicken muss.
Weil es ist nicht so einfach, die Klimaanlage zu steuern. Ich hab ja so eine...
...Mitsubishi Heavy Z... Oh, ich weiß es nicht, was ich für eine genau hab.
Aber sowas. Im Prinzip sowas in dieser Richtung hab ich ja.
So. Und... Das ist ein bisschen dumm gemacht, weil die Klimaanlage selbst hat so gut wie keine Logik.
Die Logik ist alles in der Fernbedienung zum größten Teil.
Also das heißt, wenn ich die Klimaanlage eingestellt hab, sagen wir auf 25 Grad und Lüftung nur nach links und ich mach die Batterien aus der Fernbedienung raus...
...und ich schalte, mach die Batterien raus aus der Fernbedienung, mach die Batterie wieder rein und schalte die Klimaanlage an, dann fährt die eben die Fall-Zustand hoch.
Also die Logik und das Speichern ist in der Fernbedienung drinne. Das ist ziemlich dumm.
Deswegen schickt die Fernbedienung auch nicht einfach nur ein An- oder Aussignal an die Klimaanlage, sondern die Fernbedienung schickt jedes Mal den kompletten State an die Klimaanlage.
Also die Fernbedienung schickt jedes Mal, fragt mich nicht, 108 Spite State an die Klimaanlage zum Einschalten und bei jedem Kommando.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ziemlich beknackt, aber es ist halt so. So, wartet mal kurz.
So, Excel. Das ist kein WLAN, das ist Infrarot und da drüber viel zu verschicken ist immer eher so ein Ding. So, und deswegen musste ich damals so ein Infrarot-Mitschneidetool verwenden, dass dieses komplette Signal mitschneiden konnte und ich das dann diesem RM3 beibringen konnte über Home Assistant.
Mittlerweile verwende ich das Ding nicht mehr dafür, sondern habe ja eine eigene Steuerung gebastelt mit dem ESP32, da hatten wir hier eine schöne Library gefunden.
Weiß nicht, ob es das war. Das könnte es sogar gewesen sein. Ist das eine andere Library als die, die wir verwendet haben? Ach, Via Connector, das ist was anderes, genau.
Wir haben was anderes verwendet. Ist auch egal, wenn ihr es wissen wollt, guckt euch einfach den Stream im Archiv vom Sebaro an. Tja, wie gesagt, alle mal besser als in Harmony Hub und auch deutlich erweiterbarer.
So, jetzt wollte ich endlich mal dieses eine Video noch fertig gucken. Wir haben es heute geschafft im ganzen Stream zwei Videos zu gucken oder so.
Also Weiß-Sensor hole ich mir nicht. Schau mal OpenWrt angeschaut. Ja, ich habe aber keine Hardware für, wo sich das lohnen würde.
Und auf dem MikroTik-Ding, glaube ich, könnte man das theoretisch installieren, aber da bleibe ich lieber bei offiziellen Router OS.
Wie gesagt, Weiß hole ich mir nicht. Weiß ist nur sinnvoll, wenn man irgendwie in diesem Weiß-Ökosystem drin ist. Ich habe ein paar Kameras von denen, aber auch nur, weil die damals 20 Dollar bei Amazon gekostet haben.
Da habe ich mir drei Stück davon, drei Stück davon bestellt und eine ist schon komplett kaputt und die andere habe ich im Flur stehen, dann habe ich noch eine im Keller und noch eine hinten im Zimmer, wo die Katze immer, da wo die Katze ihren Klo hat.
Ja, ist auch so. Wie lahm das ist. Das ist übrigens noch ein Punkt, warum es sogar besser ist, man macht das selbst.
Da kann man an ganz vielen Parametern rumstellen und unter anderem auch Latency beeinflussen.
Bei mir ist es so, wenn ich anschalte im Home Assistant mein Licht im Wohnzimmer, ich drücke im Home Assistant drauf und das ist an. Das hat keine halbe Sekunde oder Sekunde Verzögerung.
Das sind vielleicht, keine Ahnung, 150 Millisekunden oder so. Click BAM.
Genauso wie im Bad die Heizung und alles oder die Heizung im Wohnzimmer und so. Das geht alles ultra schnell.
Also Leute, ich darf das mit Sicherheit. Ich darf ja auch an meiner PS5 rumschrauben, allerdings darf Sony danach sagen, nö, wir tauschen die nicht mehr um.
Natürlich ist es eine Sache, wenn ich jetzt an der Steckdose selbst rumschraube und danach, keine Ahnung, danach kriege ich einen Stromschlag und muss ins Krankenhaus.
Dann kann das durchaus sein, oder gerade wenn ich das auch noch live im Stream mache, das kann durchaus sein, dass meine Versicherung sagt, ne Max, das bezahlen wir nicht.
Warum schraubst du auch so dumm an deiner Steckdose rum? Klar, machen kann ich aber trotzdem.
Und es ist auch nicht so, dass dann die Polizei bei mir auf der Tür steht und sagt, Max, du hast an deiner Stromschlag, du hast, also ich habe mich gar nicht an meiner Steckdose rumgeschraubt, sondern an einem Smart Home IoT Device, dass dann die Polizei vor der Tür steht.
Diese SmartThings Sensoren benutzen ZigBee, also braucht ihr einen Hub, der zum Preis kommt.
Auch wenn ihr Alexa-Routines mit Weissens triggert, müsstet ihr warten, bis sie kompatibel sind.
Weiss-Kameras sind nicht kompatibel mit Weissens.
Verwendet jemand von euch daheim regelmäßig Alexa? Ich meine haben und einmal verwendet haben und cool finden und nie wieder verwenden ist das ein, aber wirklich regelmäßig?
Echt, okay.
Und steuert sein Smart Home mit Alexa, okay.
Tatsächlich, weil ihr wisst ja, ich bin kein Voice Assistant Fan.
Die einzige Sache, wo ich es halt okay finde, ist keine Ahnung, Siri im Auto oder so, das ist noch in Ordnung, aber ansonsten bin ich ja Fan von Knöpfen und Tastaturen.
Ich meine, bei mir ist es so, ich habe einen NFC-Tag am Bett und wenn ich mein Handy auf den NFC-Tag lege, bzw. das Handy eigentlich umgedreht ist es so, ich halte das Handy als NFC-Tag und der NFC-Tag scannt das, dann bekommt das meine Heimautomatisierung mit, kann Licht dimmen und Sachen ausmachen und alles.
Warum müsste ich dann sagen, Alexa Licht aus?
Ich habe da so den richtigen Mehrwert für mich noch nicht gefunden, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Dann brauchst du kein NFC-Tag mehr, aber das ist ja überhaupt nicht, belastet mich ja überhaupt nicht.
Ich leg das Handy ja eh dahin, es ist sogar besser, weil dann weiß ich auf jeden Fall, wenn es Licht ausgeht, ich hab das Handy neben dem Bett liegen.
Ich will ja das Handy neben dem Bett liegen haben, also für mich ist es sogar noch besser, ich kann damit sicherstellen, dass ich das Handy neben dem Bett liegen hab.
Also wie gesagt, ich hab für mich da noch nicht so den großen Vorteil erkannt. Also eine Sache, wo ich es mir als sinnvoll vorstelle, allerdings jetzt nicht mit Alexa und mit Alexa Skills, ist die Home Assistant App auf IOS.
Die kann ja mittlerweile ziemlich viel, diese Home Assistant Companion App, die kann man sich ja auch in Shortcuts reinhängen und sowas.
Also was man damit machen könnte, wäre zum Beispiel einen Voice Command machen, was dann eine Home Assistant Automation triggert.
Das ist dann zwar kein Alexa und es ist auch nicht so wirklich komplett Siri, aber man kann ja Shortcuts einstellen, dass Shortcuts mit Voice Commands getriggert werden können.
Dann könnte ich mir zum Beispiel einen Voice Command machen, was dann andere Home Automatisierungen triggert. Das wäre noch was, das finde ich nicht schlecht, wenn es was ist, wo es sich anbietet, über Sprachsteuerungen zu machen.
Zum Beispiel, wahrgenommen man steht irgendwie unter der Dusche, ich reihe mir jetzt mal ein bisschen was zusammen, wahrgenommen man steht unter der Dusche, hat aber sein iPhone dabei und möchte, es gibt ja Leute, die haben Musik an im Bad, dass man denen die Playlist ändert oder so.
Das stelle ich mir dann sinnvoll vor. Wir gucken gleich das Video zu Ende, ich will jetzt ja schon seit 30 Minuten gucken. Wie funktioniert das mit den NFC Tags, braucht man da eine App für?
Also das mit den NFC Tags ist so, es ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich, je nachdem, was es für einen Hersteller ist, aber prinzipiell braucht man zwei Sachen, man braucht einmal, dafür müsste Siri die ganze Zeit lauschen,
man braucht einmal ein Smartphone, was NFC Sachen drin hat, also man braucht die Antenne da drin, in dem Gerät, sonst geht es nicht, logischerweise. So und dann kann man, bei iOS zumindest, kann man die eingebaute Shortcuts App verwenden und man scannt den NFC Tag und ich glaube, Shortcuts schreibt dann auf diesen NFC Tag irgendeine random Nummer drauf, die es wieder erkennt.
Das Schöne an NFC Tags ist, der Kram kostet nur ein paar Cent. Und bei NFC Tags muss man halt immer wissen, eigentlich ist es klar, aber woher habe ich denn das Video jetzt überhaupt, dass es eben so rum ist, dass das Handy, das Smartphone, den NFC Tag scannt und nicht etwa der NFC Tag das Smartphone erkennt und reagiert.
Also sprich, wenn ihr Besuch habt und ihr möchtet, dass der Besuch mit seinem Handy die Heizung im Bad einschalten kann, dann geht das nicht, weil nicht der NFC Tag was macht, sondern das Handy was macht, nachdem es den NFC Tag gescannt hat.
Gibt es für Android was Vergleichbares für Shortcuts? Ja, unter Android geht das sogar noch besser. Unter Android kannst du ganz, ganz viele Sachen verwenden. Tasker ist somit das verbreitetste. Es ist wie immer oder wie oft bei iOS und Android.
Shortcuts ist von der Usability her. Meilenweit von dem, was man in Tasker hat, dafür kann man mit Tasker mehr machen und auch viel mehr im Hintergrund und automatisch machen.
Dazu kommt, dass du unter Android noch viel mehr Automatisierungsmöglichkeiten hast. Du kannst mit Thermux, glaube ich heißt das, komplettes vollständiges Linux-System im Hintergrund laufen lassen, was für dich Sachen macht.
Also du hast unter Android wie immer viel, viel mehr Möglichkeiten, auch ohne User-Interaktion und sonst wie was zu machen automatisch. Dafür ist die Usability nicht so polished wie unter iOS.
Und das ist ja eine Sache, das zieht sich so komplett durch. Also wenn man mal wirklich so ein Android versus iOS Ding machen will, dann ist das ein Thema, das ist eigentlich fast überall so.
Du kannst potentiell unter Android mehr Sachen verbiegen und customisen und abgedrehte Hacks machen. Dafür ist die Bedienung unter iOS oftmals mehr polished.
Ja. Für Tasker weiß ich nicht, ob du ein Plugin brauchst. Ich habe NFC mit Tasker noch nie gemacht, weil keines meiner Android-Geräte NFC hat.
Ich habe ja nur Android-Tablets, ich habe ja kein Android-Smartphone. Deswegen habe ich es noch nicht mal ausprobiert mit. So, wir gucken jetzt das Video erstmal fertig.
Die habe ich, die habe ich übrigens. Das sind drei Stück davon bestellt und drei Stück von diesen paar Zoom-Cams. Aber als die noch 20 Euro gekostet haben, 20 Dollar bei Amazon kommen.
Ich finde es gut, dass das ausblendet. Ja, IFTTT ist auch lahm. IFTTT geht ja auch übers Internet.
Weder noch, weder noch. Das Beste ist billig China-Sensor und ein Custom-Software, die es steuert.
Gut, das geht in Deutschland nicht. Das geht hier nicht. Das geht bei uns nicht, weil wir haben Wände aus Stein und nicht Wände aus Holz.
Es gibt Länder, die haben Wände aus Holz. Da geht das wunderbar. Bei uns musste dann erstmal so einen komischen, wie heißt das? Wie heißt das, wo man die Löcher in die Wand schneidet bei uns?
Wo man auch Steckdosen ausschneidet und so. Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt. Entweder brauchst du einen super heftigen Akkuschlitzer. Ja, sowas in der Richtung, genau.
Von Hilti, Hilti ist der Hersteller. Es gibt aber auch für richtig fette Akkuschrauber, gibt es solche Steckdosen-Aufschneide-Aufsätze.
Dann komme ich aber mit meinem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber nicht so weit damit. Denke ich mal, weiß ich nicht, habe ich noch nie probiert.
Aber wenn du einen richtig fetten Akkuschrauber hast und so eine Steckdose-Aufsatz, dann wird das schon funktionieren.
Dosenbohrer, genau, sowas da. Sowas. Ja, genau sowas hier meine ich. Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Aber da komme ich wahrscheinlich mit meinem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber nicht weit. Da brauchst du ein bisschen was dickeres.
Aber da habe ich halt keinen Anwendungszweck für, deswegen habe ich auch keinen fetteren.
Also funktioniert in Deutschland gar nicht.
Eats, Gott, der Eats Smart dimmer ist das.
Eats.
Ja, wenn man eine Wand hat.
Ich verwende gar nichts davon. Ich verwende Shortcuts mit der iOS Home Assistant Companion App.
Ich verwende einfach nur Shortcuts, weil das so ein Apple Ausnahmeding wieder ist.
Also sprich, wenn du im Hintergrund Sachen machen willst, dann musst du es mit Shortcuts machen, weil sie mal wieder eine Ausnahme haben im Vergleich zu anderen Apps.
zu anderen apps. also nfc tag scannen und home assistant automation anwerfen geht nur mit short
cuts weil alle anderen apps brauchen user input rückfrage. ja homekit ist optisch das ist so
ein typisches apple ding. usability und generell UI frontend ist halt ultra polished. ich habe es
halt ganz gern wenn ich da unabhängig von bin. erstens weil ich es auf allen möglichen geräten
verwenden will. auf meinem fernseher, auf meinen android tablets, auf meinem ios gerät, zusätzliche
schalter im haus und haste nicht gesehen. und weil ich halt alle möglichen geräte zusammen verwenden
möchte unabhängig davon ob das jetzt homekit supportet oder nicht. deswegen mache ich es halt
so ich habe mein home assistant als zentrale steuer ding und sende halt im zweifelsfall nur
requests dahin und der macht es dann für mich. und ich mache halt mit short cuts, also dieses
eine ding hier ist es ja. ich habe ja nur zwei sachen gemacht mit short cuts bisher. einmal wenn
ich mich ins bett lege das licht ausgeschaltet wird und sowas und dann noch diese sache hier
auf dem klo wo ich hier einen nfc tag auf dem klo habe und meinen heizlüfter und ich halte
mein handy an den nfc tag und zack geht der heizlüfter an und wieder aus. und das ganze
geht nur weil ich so eine geflechte steckdose habe die über home assistant und das motor
angebunden ist und mein handy geht dann da dran und also hier an diesen nfc tag und schickt
über shortcuts home assistant ein request und home assistant schaltet die steckdose an. ja
und es ist natürlich wichtig dass man es auf dem klo schön warm hat. ja das bringt wirklich
was. ohne scheiß smarte steckdosen ist eines der besten sachen die man sich kaufen kann.
also wenn man instant benefits haben will von irgendwelchen smart home sachen. geräte
remote an und ausschalten ist eines der besten sachen und manchmal zu wissen was die verbrauchen
ist auch nicht schlecht. wie gesagt ich habe hier unten an der einen steckdose so gemacht wenn man
den akkustaubsauger lädt und es unter vier watt verbrauch fällt dann schaltet er automatisch
aus weil dann ist er voll. ich könnte den fenster senso ans klo deckel machen ja. aber wozu. tja oder
man kauft sich einen vierer pack china dinger. ja das ist eine gute idee. das ist echt eine gute
idee. was man damit auch machen könnte fällt mir gerade ein. ich bin dann die ganze zeit schon
überlegen ob ich den wäschetrockner oder besser oder die waschmaschine den wäschetrockner nicht
das irgendwie so baue dass ich bescheid kriege wenn er fertig ist und das beste dürfte wahrscheinlich
wirklich sein den an so einen smart plug anzuschließen der misst wie viel strom durchgeht
und sobald es quasi dann aufhört viel zu verbrauchen über sagen wir über 15 minuten dann ist das ding
wahrscheinlich fertig bist du das klar das habe ich mir tatsächlich lustigerweise gerade gestern
überlegt ich bin ja gerade am object detection machen mit der kamera und die kamera hat ja im
also die im hof hat hier so nachtsicht modus problem ist halt der nachtsicht modus ist halt
nachtsicht modus für die kamera nicht für mich und gestern oder wann auch immer bin ich bin ich
heimgekommen da war es schon dunkel es ist ja recht frühdunkel und da bin ich durch den hof
komplett im dunklen gelaufen und im flur war auch dunkel und ich habe die tür aufgemacht und musste
erst mal den lichtschalter ertasten habe ich mir gedacht warum gebe ich mir diesen scheiß überhaupt
warum mache ich es nicht so dass ich einmal die lichter remote vom handy anschalten könnte und
warum mache ich nicht einfach den bewegungssensor oder zumindest mal in den haustür geht auf und
zu sensor in verbindung mit dem flurlicht dran
ja smartphone taschenlampe aber besser ist wenn es automatisch geht
die mag ich überhaupt nicht die alo dinger
die mag ich gar nicht
man braucht kein smartes outdoor light jedes stinknormale outdoor light
reicht da macht man einfach einen schalter dran den man schalten kann remote und man braucht
kein smartes outdoor light light also smart light klingt eh schon so als ist das jetzt
intelligenter das lichter die shelly schalter ja die shelly schalter zeige ich so ziemlich jedes
mal im stream
siehst du siehst du siehst du deswegen mache ich objekterkennung in der kamera dass er erkennt wenn
leute dran vorbeilaufen oder zumindest will ich das mal wer sich mal wieder fragt warum ich den
kram pro kamie so i ended up putting an arlo camera next to the arlo light to see if anybody was
actually there the arlo light does have some extra features like it can strobe or change colors
but the main thing i use it for is turning on a white light for motion which the solar light does
very well look at the footage of me on an arlo ultra camera being lit by the arlo light in a
solar powered light the arlo light is slightly brighter and more of a true white color the solar
light man könnte einfach eine ganz man könnte man könnte einfach eine stink normale lampe dahin
hängen die wäre wahrscheinlich billiger und besser machst du objekte detection heute noch
weiter könnte sogar sein dass wir heute noch weiter programmieren gestern abend ja noch
neuen stand gepusht und ich habe noch nie ausprobieren flexart das video jeder der rgb lampen
sucht kann ich dem das video von dem typ echt empfehlen da zwei videos gemacht zu rgb lampen
richtig gut und hat letztendlich auch ausschlag gegeben für mich dass ich mal diese livex dinge
ausprobieren eines der besten sachen die man sich kaufen kann für daheim hast du nicht objekte
erkennung von ja schon fertiggestellt ne vor einem jahr haben wir mit open cv mal ein bisschen
motion erkennung ausprobiert die aber war weitem nicht so gut funktioniert wie die neue objekte
erkennung if they went with the wise cam versus something like an arlo camera the truth is you
wouldn't be missing out on that much besides something like an arlo ultra which is 4k in a
wider viewing angle looking at an arlo pro to the good 4k in the cameras is also camera in a
wise dazu useless both are 1080p if free cloud storage but wise has doubled the amount of free
cloud storage wise can also record continuously to an sd card for free and it has person detection
for free which is insane for how insane camera is for an indoor camera i would definitely go with
a wise cam as for outdoors it's a different story because arlo pros have that rechargeable battery
make it easy to put anywhere outside even though wise cams aren't supposed to go out das habe ich
ausprobiert ich hatte so ein ding draußen stehen allerdings nicht die sondern die pan von denen ich
hatte auch so ein hütchen drauf und es ist genauso sinnlos wie es aussieht mit dem hütchen also das
ist im prinzip so eine silikonhülle für die kamera und die ist mir bestimmt alle paar bestimmt alle
was weiß ich eins bis drei monate ist mir das ding verreckt und ich musste die sd karte neu
machen und sonst was und jetzt am schluss ist der sd kartenslot komplett kaputt und ich konnte sie
überhaupt nicht mehr starten also die dinger sind wirklich nicht für außen gedacht das einzige was
ich mir vorstellen könnte ist außen unter einem dach also sprich wenn man die hier hinhängt unter
das dach dann mag das ok sein aber ich hatte die außen am kirchenfenster und da hat es halt auch
drauf geregnet und alles die das ging nicht das hat es nicht ausgehalten die dinger sind wirklich nicht
für outdoor gedacht ich habe mir noch nichts bei amazon geholt nie war nichts dabei bisher das
problem ist max ris du musst die du musst die darfst du nicht bei amazon bestellen viel zu teuer im
offiziellen shop kosten die weniger aber die verzentren glaube ich nach deutschland deswegen
sind die mittlerweile useless diese kameras lohnen sich wirklich nur wenn sie 20 20 bis 25 dollar
kosten dann ist es ok und dann kann man die auch bei amazon bestellen dann bezahlt man auch mal 20
dollar import dazu aber wenn man sich sechs stück bestellt dann lohnt sich das wieder ansonsten
würde ich was anderes suchen das funktioniert nicht das war die kameras mit batterie sacken ich
brauche kameras die 24 7 streamen können es lohnt sich immer vom fall zu fall manchmal lohnt sich
mehr auszugeben und manchmal nicht wie bei vielen sachen übrigens leute habe ich euch schon meine
heizungs meine meine heizungsüberwachung gezeigt ich habe letztens festgestellt gestern war das
sogar ich habe gestern festgestellt dass meine heizung nicht geht das passt mal auf man sieht
hier glaube ich sogar gestern so mittags irgendwann war das war gestern 22 man sieht man sieht es gar
nicht hier drauf es sieht so aus als ging es die ganze zeit aber es war ja auch nicht lang
lassen wir überlegen gestern nachmittag irgendwann gestern um doch hier guck mal hier nehmen wir hier
hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut ich so mal kurz ran hallo da ging es nicht so gerade hier so
gerade hier so ging es nicht und bis ich dann gecheckt habe woran das woran das lag ich hab
nämlich hab mich nämlich gewundert hier guck mal die temperatur ist teilweise unten und die
pumpe pumpt nicht und was ist denn los mit meiner heizung so und bis ich dann drauf gekommen bin
ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich euch zeigen kann weil ich will nichts liegen kann ich kann ich
euch nicht zeigen weil ich sonst was liege ich versuch ich versuch es mal aufzumachen kurz so
dass man sieht es ist nämlich die karte übersicht von meiner kamera im haus und im hof
mal kurz runterscrollen so dass man nix sieht
das ist jetzt leak
leute ich habe den ich habe meinen browser kaputt gemacht what the fuck na gut man sieht
eh nix gerade hier unten ist nämlich die kamera die ich im keller hab im keller hab für die
für die heizung und hier sehe ich den den druck vom wasser und da habe ich festgestellt ok in
meiner überwachung dass ich habe pumpe pumpt nicht richtig temperatur ist nicht richtig und
habe ich auf die kamera geguckt festgestellt der druck der wasserdruck war ganz hier unten kein
wunder dass sie nicht mehr pumpen konnte übrigens das ist auch so ein monka es ding eigentlich
bedeutet dass das irgendwas undicht ist sondern habe ich wasser nachgefüllt und bäum ging
hat wieder funktioniert alles nur weil ich meine überwachung gesehen habe also das ding hat sich
schon mal gelohnt nee geht nicht weil das ist ein extra sensor den man nicht über die api von
der heizung auslesen kann das ist ein extra sensor das heißt ich müsste einen eigenen
druck sensor hin machen den ich auslesen könnte dass das funktioniert gut das wieder mal jetzt
fertig geguckt leute ich gehe jetzt was essen ich habe übelst hunger hast du eine übersicht
für stromverbrauch von dein tas motor geflashten steckdosen nur eine nur eine der steckdosen hat
messungen für stromverbrauch oder meinst du was die strom was die steckdose selber verbraucht
das habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie überprüft was die steckdose selber verbraucht aber das wird
sich im milliampere bereich bewegen was so ein esp 2866 da verbraucht strommesser also nicht
rum ist und wie gesagt da habe ich nur eine da habe ich nur eine das ist ja auch die wo ich wo
ich im stream versucht habe noch eine andere umzubauen andere vom gleichen typ das funktioniert
ganz brauchbar feifelt was sich automatisch nachfüllt bei geringem druck dann bräuchte
noch irgendwas wo ich den han unten aufmachen könnte ja also das funktioniert ganz okay mit
dem stromverbrauch ist vielleicht nicht so richtig genau aber so ungefähr passt das schon da ist die
daten von einer steckdose das ist das motor und das schickt das über mqtt und mein homo system
werte das aus ich habe die steckdose so eingestellt dass sie alle zehn sekunden mqtt status verschickt
moment ob ich dir zeigen kann hat was ist der neu so hier staubsauger da sieht man es
das ist die steckdose wo unten das staubsauger dran hängt wenn er auflädt aktuell ist er aus
könnte ich anschalten und hier sieht man wo das staubsauger dran war oder oder es könnte auch
bei der stimmte übrigens nicht dabei das staubsauger nicht dran da war
schichtes radio an oder so admin admin easy ja das geht über das das das motor über mqtt
direkt an homo system und hier war er zwischenzeitlich mal an wenn du eine
schönere history willst kannst du das dann auch noch in grafana abbilden so leute excellent
stream ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen ich speichere mir mal die ganzen tabs
bookmark all tabs session folder und zwar von 22.11.2020 also reicht es zack
können wir nächstes mal weiter gucken also macht's gut wir sehen uns ich muss jetzt was
essen ich hab übelst hunger vielleicht heute mittag wird weiter programmiert am aufnahme tool
und wir sehen uns bis denn macht's gut zu